I'm Jenna Fischer. And I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together. And we're best friends. And now we're doing the Ultimate Office rewatch podcast just for you. Each week we will break down an episode of The Office and give exclusive behind the scenes stories that only two people who were there can tell you. We're The Office ladies. Hello. Hi there. Okay. Hi. It's Ed. Hi. Surprise, you guys. We have Ed Helms here today. And we will be talking about Andy's play. I didn't know if I was supposed to talk right away or if you were going to introduce me or that but then you both looked at me. We just stared at you until you spoke. Okay. So yeah, I'm talking. Now I'm talking. I'm here. Well, this is
我是詹娜·费舍。我是安吉拉·金斯尼。我们一起演过《办公室》。我们是最好的朋友。现在我们专门为你制作了《办公室》终极重温播客。每周我们都会剖析一集《办公室》，并提供只有当时身临其境的两个人才能告诉你的独家幕后故事。我们是办公室女士。你好。嗨。好的。嗨。是埃德。嗨。你们好呀，给你们个惊喜。我们今天请到了埃德·海尔姆斯。我们将讨论安迪的戏剧。我不知道我是不是应该马上说话，还是你们要介绍我，或者什么的，但接着你们俩都看着我。我们一直盯着你，直到你开口。好吧。所以，是的，我在说话。现在我在说话。我在这。好吧，这是
season seven episode three. It was written by Charlie Grandi directed by John Scott. Would you like a summary? I mean, I would love more. Ed, what do you think about summary? I love summaries. I love a summary. Here it is. Andy invites his co-workers to watch him in a community theater production of Sweeney Todd, which Michael is upset to learn he was not cast in. The entire office attends except for Aaron, who steps in at the last minute to babysit for CeCe. And Angela is going to get another punch on her punch card from Dwight but not for the reason you might think. There it is. What do we think? Mm-hmm. Did I cover it? It's actually, yeah. I rewatched the episode in preparation for this and that summary is
第七季第三集。由查理·格兰迪编剧，约翰·斯科特执导。你想听总结吗？我是说，我很想听更多。埃德，你觉得总结怎么样？我喜欢总结。我喜欢总结。给你。安迪邀请他的同事们去看他在社区剧院制作的《理发师陶德》，迈克尔得知自己没有被选上后感到很难过。整个办公室的人都去了，除了艾琳，她在最后一分钟介入去给西西当保姆。安吉拉将从德 Dwight 那里得到打孔卡的又一个印章，但原因可能和你想象的不同。就是这样。大家觉得呢？嗯。我概括了吗？实际上，是的。我为了做准备重温了这一集，那个总结
spot on. Oh, thank you. Yeah. I wrote it myself. I also thought maybe we want a quick summary of Sweeney Todd, the production that Andy is starring in to give some context. What do you guys think? I want to hear it. I went down the Wikipedia rabbit hole about Sweeney Todd and wow. Oh, well, I hope I cover it. If I don't, will you let me know? Maybe. Oh, no, I didn't commit any of it to memory. There's just a lot of versions. I don't know anything about it. So I won't know if, I mean, I know what is in the episode basically, but I don't know the musical and I know the premise, but I don't know the story. So anything you say is going to be fine with me. All right. Well, here we go. Sweeney Todd, the demon barber
非常贴切。哦，谢谢。是的。我自己写的。我还以为也许我们想对安迪主演的制作《理发师陶德》做一个快速总结，以提供一些背景。大家觉得呢？我想听。我为了《理发师陶德》深入研究了维基百科，哇。哦，好吧，希望我能涵盖它。如果我漏掉了，你能提醒我吗？也许吧。哦，不，我什么都没记住。有很多版本。我对它一无所知。所以我不知道，我的意思是，我基本上知道这一集里有什么，但我不知道这部音乐剧，我知道这个前提，但不知道故事。所以你说什么我都行。好吧。那么，我们开始吧。理发师陶德，恶魔理发师
of Fleet Street is a real musical that first opened on Broadway in 1979. The music and lyrics are by Stephen Sondheim and the book is by Hugh Wheeler. The character of Sweeney Todd, a murderous barber who goes around killing people. It originated in Victorian serialized fiction known as the Penny Dreadfuls. Yes. I saw that on Wikipedia. I have one little beef with your summary, actually. Are you done? You're not done. I have a little more to say. Okay, go for it. Okay. Sorry. No. Already one beef I've earned. All right. The musical was based on a play by Christopher Bond, where he introduced a psychological backstory for Todd's crimes. And Stephen Sondheim had seen this play and
弗利街是一部真正的音乐剧，于1979年在百老汇首演。音乐和歌词由斯蒂芬·桑德海姆创作，剧本由休·惠勒创作。理发师陶德这个角色，一个到处杀人的凶残理发师。它起源于被称为“低俗小说”的维多利亚时代连载小说。是的。我在维基百科上看到了。实际上，我对你的总结有一个小小的意见。你说完了吗？你还没说完。我还有话要说。好吧，请说。好吧。抱歉。不。我已经招致了一个意见。好吧。音乐剧改编自克里斯托弗·邦的一部戏剧，他在剧中引入了陶德犯罪的心理背景。斯蒂芬·桑德海姆看过这部戏，并
that inspired him to write the musical. Over 80% of Sweeney Todd is set to music either through singing or an underscore to dialogue. And the musical won both the Tony and the Olivier Award for Best New Musical when it came out. When was that that it came out? 1979. What's your beef, Ed? Okay. So you said that he goes around killing people. He actually is a barber and he murders people in his barbershop. So really, people come around to be murdered. Exactly. Yes. That would have been more accurate. He doesn't go around murdering. People come around to get murdered. They're accurate. They come around for a haircut.
这启发了他创作这部音乐剧。《理发师陶德》中超过80%的内容都有音乐相伴，通过演唱或对话的背景音乐。这部音乐剧问世时，荣获了托尼奖和奥利弗奖的最佳新音乐剧奖。那是什么时候问世的？1979年。你的意见是什么，埃德？好的。所以你说他到处杀人。他实际上是个理发师，他在自己的理发店里谋杀人们。所以实际上，人们是来被谋杀的。Exactly。是的。那样会更准确。他不是到处谋杀。人们是来被谋杀的。它们很准确。他们是来理发的。
They come around for a haircut. Then he kills them with the straight razor. Right. And then he opens the chair. He has a lever and they go flying down into the basement. And then he has a friend who turns their bodies into meat for really bad men's pies. Aren't they really yummy? Oh, yeah. Sorry. She has a song at the beginning that she has really bad pies. Oh. When the pies are people, then they're good. Yeah. Then people can't get enough of the pies. Oh my God. I did not realize this part of the story. Oh, yeah. Oh, yeah.
他们是来理发的。然后他用直剃刀杀了他们。对。然后他打开椅子。他有一个杠杆，他们就会飞进地下室。然后他有一个朋友，把他们的尸体做成非常糟糕的男士肉馅饼。它们难道不好吃吗？哦，是的。抱歉。她一开始有一首歌，说她的肉馅饼真的很糟糕。哦。当馅饼是人的时候，它们就很好吃。是的。然后人们对馅饼爱不释手。我的天啊。我没有意识到故事的这一部分。哦，是的。哦，是的。
There's a whole cannibalism. I mean, it's like accidental cannibalism. They sell them as mince pies, but they're people. It's like soiling green. Yeah. It's people. Yeah. It's people. It's people. It's people. Come on, people. Yeah. People pies. People pies. Wow. The musical could have been called people pies.
这里面有整个食人肉情节。我的意思是，这就像意外食人。他们把它们当成肉馅饼卖，但它们是人。这就像《超世纪谍杀案》里的。是的。是人。是的。是人。是人。是人。拜托，伙计们。是的。人肉馅饼。人肉馅饼。哇。这部音乐剧本可以叫人肉馅饼。
It should have been. It should have been, really. We got to write Stephen Sondheim a letter. Yeah. Getting out of my old tummy type of it. Well, Ed, we can't wait to talk to you about this episode and your experience. We thought we'd start by asking you, do you have any musical theater background? Yeah. Have you ever been in musicals? Like in high school?
本来就应该叫这个。真的应该叫这个。我们得给斯蒂芬·桑德海姆写封信。是的。从我老肚子里解放出来的那种感觉。好吧，埃德，我们迫不及待地想和你聊聊这一集和你的经历。我们想先问你，你有任何音乐剧背景吗？是的。你演过音乐剧吗？比如在高中？
Well, yeah. So I was in some musical theater productions in high school, and then I was in, let's see, I was in Joseph and the Amazing Technicolor Dreamcoat. Okay. Oh, Jenna and I both have one. We're wondering if you're in. Keep going. And gosh, I'm drawing up a line. Oh, I was in Into the Woods, another Sondheim. Oh, yes, Into the Woods. Another Sondheim masterpiece. And that was all high school. And then when I was in college, I did, I was in a musical called The Cradle Will Rock, which is a really cool, like a,
嗯，是的。所以我在高中的时候参演过一些音乐剧制作，然后我参演了，让我想想，我参演了《约瑟夫的神奇彩衣》。好的。哦，珍娜和我都有一个。我们在想你有没有演。继续。天哪，我卡壳了。哦，我演了《拜访森林》，又一部桑德海姆的作品。哦，是的，《拜访森林》。另一部桑德海姆的杰作。那都是高中时期的事。然后我上大学的时候，我演过，我参演了一部名为《摇篮将晃》的音乐剧，那真的是一部很酷的，像，
during the Great Depression, it was written as like a sort of pro worker. Anyway, it's a cool piece. And that's when I did in college. And then I think that's it. Wow. No Guys and Dolls, Jenna. We really, we were really feeling like that'd be a good role for you. Yeah. Nathan Detroit. Yeah, sure.
在大萧条时期，它被写成了一种类似亲工人的作品。不管怎样，这是一部很酷的作品。那是我上大学时演的。然后我想就这些了。哇。没有《红男绿女》吗，珍娜？我们真的，我们真的觉得那会是一个适合你的角色。是的。内森·底特律。是的，当然。
Guys and Dolls. Sit down, sit down, sit down, sit down. Yeah. Sit down here. I remember. Okay. I don't, I'm not that, I don't know Guys and Dolls and I wasn't in it, but I wish I was. Cause then we'd have a lot more to talk about. Did you do musical theater, Angela?
《红男绿女》。坐下，坐下，坐下，坐下。是的。坐这儿。我记得。好吧。我不，我没那么，我不知道《红男绿女》，我也没有演过，但我希望我演过。因为那样我们就有更多的话题了。你演过音乐剧吗，安吉拉？
Oh, I mean, I was in the Music Man at my school in Indonesia. Awesome. I played Amarilis and we thought it was really funny. We would give everyone a nickname based off their character name. So everyone called me, I'm a real ass. Oh. Yeah. So you, your life has just been a series of nicknames. People love nicknaming you. Numbone. I'm a real ass. That was my big musical theater debut, but I actually get really anxious
哦，我是说，我在印尼的学校里演过《音乐人》。太棒了。我扮演阿玛丽莉丝，我们觉得这真的很有趣。我们会根据每个人的角色名给他们起绰号。所以每个人都叫我，“我是个真正的屁股（I'm a real ass）”。哦。是的。所以你，你的人生只是一系列绰号。人们喜欢给你起绰号。笨骨头。我是个真正的屁股。那是我的音乐剧大荧幕首秀，但我其实对
singing in front of people. I can be on stage doing, you know, zany comedy skits and things like that, but to sing in front of people makes me so anxious. So I opted then to go into the more serious theater productions. Of course. I see. What about you? Yeah. I did in high school. I'm not a strong singer, so I was in the dance chorus.
在人们面前唱歌感到非常焦虑。我可以上台表演，你知道的，滑稽的喜剧短剧之类的，但在人们面前唱歌让我如此焦虑。所以我选择去更严肃的戏剧制作中。当然。我明白。你呢？是的。我在高中时演过。我不是一个强有力的歌手，所以我加入了舞蹈合唱团。
I've heard you sing. I think you have a great voice. Thank you for saying that. I'm really self-conscious about it. Oh, well, I think, anyway, I think you have a great voice. So you danced, you were in the chorus. I did the dancing chorus and then my senior year, I got the lead dance role in Fiddler on the Roof. I was the Fiddler. Wow. Hey.
我听过你唱歌。我觉得你有一副好嗓子。谢谢你这么说。我对此真的很不自信。哦，好吧，我认为，无论如何，我觉得你有一副好嗓子。所以你跳舞了，你在合唱团里。我跳了舞蹈合唱团，然后在我高三的时候，我得到了《屋顶上的提琴手》中的领舞角色。我演的是提琴手。哇。嘿。
Cool. To which I say without me, it was just called the Roof. Wow. Yeah, of course. That was an important role. I had no lines and didn't sing, but I danced my heart out and I pretended to fiddle. Yeah. That's awesome. I just remembered another one that I was in. What?
酷。对此我想说的是，如果没有我，它就只能叫《屋顶》了。哇。是的，当然。那是个重要的角色。我没有台词，也不会唱歌，但我尽情地跳舞，还假装拉小提琴。是的。太棒了。我刚想起来我还演过另一个。什么？
Godspell. Oh, I was in Godspell in college. Hey. I should say. I'm five. Yeah. And then, oh, and in college, I was in... It's all dancing. Bob Fosse. Oh.
《福音》。哦，我上大学时演过《福音》。嘿。我得说。我是五号。是的。然后，哦，在大学里，我演了……全是舞蹈。鲍勃·福斯。哦。
Oh. Coral slime? No. The one... Nice job us just pulling out some Fosse. I know. Liza Manelli. Cabaret.
哦。珊瑚泥？不。那个……我们俩真棒，随口说出福斯。我知道。丽莎·明内利。歌厅。
No. That's it. Thank you, Devon. Thank you, Devon. I was going to say Arthur. No. Yes. And also in college, I was in Cabaret and I got to choreograph that.
不。就是这样。谢谢你，德文。谢谢你，德文。我本来想说亚瑟。不。是的。而且在大学里，我还演过《歌厅》，我还负责编舞。
So very like dance forward musicals were my thing. I'm very impressed. Yeah. Thank you. Okay. So we are here to talk about Andy performing Sweeney Todd. Randy Cordray. We talk to Randy Cordray all the time. He's amazing. He told us the writers originally pitched the storyline over the summer between seasons six and seven. How did you first hear
所以非常注重舞蹈的音乐剧是我的菜。我印象深刻。是的。谢谢。好吧。所以我们在这里谈论安迪表演《理发师陶德》。兰迪·科德雷。我们经常和兰迪·科德雷聊天。他太棒了。他告诉我们编剧们最初是在第六季和第七季之间的夏天提出这个故事线的。你是怎么第一次听说
about it? Did they come to you and say, hey, Ed, we want to do a full musical. You're going to sing a bunch. Like, did you have any input? I don't recall knowing anything about it before the table read. I'm shocked and also not shocked. Yeah. I mean, we were so buried in whatever episode we were working on. It's not like there was a lot of extra time. But now that you mention it, I'm sure that I must have started rehearsing before, like at least the week before. Yeah, because that's hard music. Sondheim is like crazy hard music.
这件事的？他们来找你，说，嘿，埃德，我们想做一部完整的音乐剧。你要唱很多歌。比如，你有什么意见吗？我不记得在剧本围读之前听到过任何关于它的消息。我很震惊，但也并不震惊。是的。我是说，我们都深陷于我们当时在拍的那一集里。又不是说有很多额外的时间。但既然你提到了，我确信我肯定在之前就开始排练了，比如至少提前一周。是的，因为那是很难的音乐。桑德海姆的音乐就像疯狂一样难。
Yeah. Yeah. Randy told us that on his schedule, he went back and looked in his files. The only day that you guys had to rehearse all together as a cast was like the Monday morning for half a day at the theater. And then we all came and started shooting the episode. Yeah. Does that sound right? That does sound right. But if you're paying attention to the episode, there's not that
是的。是的。兰迪告诉我们，在他的日程表上，他回去查看了他的档案。你们作为演员全员一起排练的唯一一天就像是周一上午在剧院排了半天。然后我们都来了并开始拍摄这一集。是的。听起来对吗？听起来确实对。但如果你注意这一集，你看不到太多
much of the play that you see. You know, like it's not a ton of production time. So I think we really only rehearsed a couple of things. The much more complicated thing was the cold open. Yeah. Oh, yeah. And that because that was a whole song that we all learned. And then there was choreography. It looks in the execution. It looks spontaneous. Like we're just running around in the space. But obviously, it was all meticulously blocked and all of the fun dramatic flourishes that
戏剧的内容。你知道的，比如制作时间并不多。所以我认为我们实际上只排练了几件事。更复杂的事情是冷开场。是的。哦，是的。那是我们全都学过的一整首歌。然后还有编舞。在执行中看起来它很即兴。就像我们在空间里跑来跑去一样。但很明显，所有这些都经过了精心走位，所有那些有趣的戏剧性花哨动作，
everybody is doing in that scene. That I remember being quite complicated and learning that song was very hard because, again, Sondheim, he doesn't like to write melodies that you expect. Everything kind of goes in weird directions and rhythms are weird. It's like that ends with like the cadence is like the demon barber of Fleet Street or something like that. Yeah. It's like a straight, you know, like a weird hiccupy thing and everyone had to get it right. But yeah, there was, you were just saying earlier how you are nervous to sing in front of people. And I love to sing, obviously, if anyone who knows me, I love to sing, but
每个人都在那个场景中做的。我记得那相当复杂，学那首歌非常难，因为，再次说明，桑德海姆，他不喜欢写你预期的旋律。一切都朝着奇怪的方向发展，节奏也很奇怪。就像那个结束时的节奏是这样的：弗利街的恶魔理发师，诸如此类。是的。这就像一个直接的，你知道的，就像一个奇怪的打嗝一样，每个人都必须弄对。但是的，有，你刚才还说你如何在人们面前唱歌感到紧张。我喜欢唱歌，很明显，如果任何了解我的人都知道，我喜欢唱歌，但我
I actually struggle with lyrics. And so I really have a hard time memorizing lyrics and that can then make me really anxious in a performance setting or like, you know, if I have to, you know, like there are a few times I had to sing like long songs on the office and I it just, yeah, it puts me in a panic state. So that one, that cold open was really hard. But I don't know, it was enough rehearsal time. Were you singing live when you guys did that? Or were you singing to like a playback recording? It seems live. It is. It's all live and even the stuff in the theater is live.
实际上在歌词方面很挣扎。所以我真的很难记住歌词，这会让我对表演环境感到非常焦虑，或者像，你知道的，如果我不得不，你知道的，就像有几次我不得不在办公室里唱长歌，这它真的，是的，把我置于恐慌状态。所以那个，那个冷开场真的很难。但是，我不知道，那有足够的排练时间。你们做那个的时候是现场唱歌吗？还是跟着播放录音唱的？看起来是现场的。是的。全都是现场的，甚至剧院里的东西也是现场的。
I thought so. Yeah. That was my memory too. Yeah. Oh, the, the, the, the, the boombox is fake. Like there was, you know, obviously that was that you hit you play on the boombox. And then, but I think they had a, they had a guide track sort of pumped in under the desks or something that we sang along to. But yeah, that was all real singing. I remember the first take we did of that cold open when you guys came in, we did not know anything. We had not seen you rehearse.
我也这么认为。是的。我的记忆也是这样。哦，那个，那个，那个，那个，那个手提音响是假的。就像有，很明显那是你在手提音响上按下播放。然后，但我认为他们有一个，他们在桌子下面或什么地方播放了一个导唱轨，我们跟着唱。但是的，那都是真唱。我记得我们拍那个冷开场的第一个镜头时，你们走进来了，我们什么都不知道。我们没看你们排练过。
Yeah. It was a complete surprise. I found it so delightful and amazing. It was also my first time seeing all of the costumes, which were so well done. Yeah. And it was good. You guys were good. And I didn't know if it would be good or bad. And I heard that you actually fought for the production of Sweeney Todd to be good and not bad. I did. Yeah. I was very passionate about that because I don't think that I, I mean, there
是的。这是一个完全的惊喜。我发现它太令人高兴和惊叹了。这也是我第一次看到所有的服装，做得太好了。是的。而且很好。你们演得很好。我不知道它是好还是坏。我听说你实际上为了《理发师陶德》的制作能够好而不是坏而据理力争。我确实争取了。是的。我对此充满激情，因为我不认为我，我的意思是，总有
are exceptions, but I generally don't think that like intentionally bad performance for comedy works. It feels like cheap and easy and like, and so I thought like my take on it was, and I was very happy that, that everyone in production agreed that, and, but there was a lot of discussion about it. This is obviously an amateur production. It's a little regional theater production in Scranton, Pennsylvania, but there's no reason that, that people in Scranton, Pennsylvania aren't like passionate about musical theater and extremely talented and coming from all walks of life and just really eager to do this and that maybe there's a really great director in the town who did a great job casting this thing. And then when
例外，但我通常认为为了喜剧效果而故意进行糟糕的表演是行不通的。这感觉很廉价、容易，而且，所以我认为我的看法是，而且我很高兴，制作团队中的每个人都同意，但是对此有很多讨论。这显然是一部业余制作。这是宾夕法尼亚州斯克兰顿的一部小型地方剧院制作，但没有任何理由，宾夕法尼亚州斯克兰顿的人们不对音乐剧充满激情，而且极其才华横溢，来自各行各业，真的渴望做到这一点，也许镇上有一个真正伟大的导演，把这个选角工作做得很好。然后当我们
we made the decision to sort of commit to a really good production that then also cascaded down into like, okay, so the costumes are really well done and the sets are going to look good. And, you know, Andy has a big fumble with his cell phone in the production, which is kind of like, that's the mess up, but it's Andy messing up. It's not like, it's not, it's not these, these like, you know, supporting actors who are, who came into like, you know, really sing and perform for us. They're not the butt of the joke. They're, they're part of the fabric of this, the premise of this episode. And I was excited to honor them and honor that and honor, honor regional theater in that way.
做出决定，投入到一个真正优秀的制作中时，这就连锁反应般地延伸到了，好吧，所以服装做得非常好，布景看起来也要好。而且，你知道的，安迪在制作中他的手机出了一个大洋相，这有点像，那是搞砸了，但那是安迪搞砸了。这不像，这不是，这不是那些，你知道的，来，你知道的，真正为我们唱歌和表演的配角。他们不是笑柄，他们是这个，这一集前提的一部分。我很高兴能向他们致敬，向这一点致敬，并以这种方式向地方剧院致敬。
I love that. Cause I mean, I've been to great regional theater and we've all like supported like smaller theaters and came up and doing theater and I thought that was a great choice. I'm glad you fought for it. Yeah. It made it so much more fun too. Cause yeah. I think it also played into Michael's jealousy. Like he had to sit through a great production that he wasn't a part of, you know, that Daryl's plumber was crushing it. Yeah. You know, cause you can be a plumber and still kick ass in a musical theater.
我喜欢这样。因为我是说，我去过很棒的地方剧院，我们所有人都支持过像小型剧院这样的地方，并且是通过做戏剧成长起来的，我认为这是一个伟大的选择。我很高兴你为之抗争。是的。这也让它变得有趣得多。因为，是的。我认为这也融入了迈克尔的嫉妒中。就像他不得不坐在那里看完一部他没有份参与的伟大制作，你知道的，达里尔的管道工表现太惊艳了。是的。你知道的，因为你可以是一个管道工，却依然能在音乐剧中大放异彩。
That's right. Yeah. My favorite thing when Andy's phone went off was the fact that you, you've ruined the whole plot. Oh my God. Like it wasn't so much that the phone was ringing. It's how Andy tried to justify it and he was ruined the rest of the play because, because the sweetie Todd guy gets a huge laugh with like his improv about the birds. Yeah. The little fix and then Andy just over compensates as he always does and like goes
没错。是的。当安迪的手机响的时候，我最喜欢的部分是，你毁了整个剧情。我的天啊。与其说是电话在响，不如说是安迪试图为此辩解，他毁了戏剧的其余部分，因为，因为理发师陶德那家伙关于鸟类的即兴表演赢得了巨大的笑声。是的。那个小修补，然后安迪就像他一向的那样反应过度，并且像
way too far. Yeah. He has to, has to pull it back. I loved it. Yeah. It was really actually fun. I have to say like, you know, as a fan of musical theater and then just sort of singing production stuff, like it was real, those parts of the office where Andy got to sing and do stuff like that was so fun. You know, when he serenaded Angela and John Michael Higgins came on board to like put that whole acapella thing together.
走得太远了。是的。他不得不，不得不收回来。我喜欢它。是的。实际上真的很有趣。我必须说，你知道的，作为一个音乐剧迷，然后只是那种唱歌制作的东西，办公室里安迪可以唱歌并做这样事情的部分真的太有趣了。你知道的，当他对安吉拉唱小夜曲，约翰·迈克尔·希金斯加入进来把整个阿卡贝拉放在一起时。
Man, it just like, it's really fun to put that, you sort of putting all that work in on the side or you're rehearsing in your trailer, you're getting everything kind of like, you know, you want it to be good and you want it to be tight and then you get to perform it for the cast and do it. There was the closing time bar song. Yeah. Yeah. There are just a lot of, a lot of great musical moments throughout the show. You have one of my favorite lines in this episode, Jenna, which was when you guys check in with Ellie on the phone and you're like, yeah, no, it's great to see Andy singing in the right
天哪，就像，把所有这些工作在私底下做好真的很有趣，或者你在你的化妆车里排练，你把一切都弄得像，你知道的，你希望它是好的，你希望它是紧凑的，然后你把它表演给演员们看并完成它。还有打烊酒吧之歌。是的。是的。整个剧集里有很多，很多伟大的音乐时刻。在这集里你有一句我最喜欢的台词，珍娜，就是当你们在电话里跟埃里希核实，然后你说，是的，不，很高兴看到安迪在正确的
context or something like that. I forgot what the line is, but like, no, that is it. It's so perfect because it is, that is, it actually, I agreed rewatching the episode, I was, you know, I thought it was, it was nice to see Andy singing in this context. It's usually so intrusive and so like, you know, and that's part of the why it's funny sometimes, but in this context, it actually was kind of, it was nice and it was part of something that was supposed to be that way. And it really, it gave Andy, I think, a sort of authenticity in this episode that, that he really struggles with in most of the Dunder
语境下唱歌，诸如此类。我忘了台词是什么了，但是，不，就是这样。它太完美了，因为它是，那是，实际上，我重新看了这一集，我是，（我觉得）这很好，很高兴看到安迪在这种语境下唱歌。它通常是如此具有侵入性，而且如此像，你知道的，这就是为什么它有时候很有趣的一部分，但在这个语境下，它实际上有点，它很好，而且它是应该那样的一部分。它真的，它给了安迪，我认为，在这集里有一种真实感，这是他在唐德
Mifflin universe. Well, I loved the ending of this episode. I think I rewatched it, I don't know, three or four times. It made me happy. It made my heart happy. And Daryl is playing Macy Gray's Eye Try on the piano and Andy is just belting it out. And you have this montage of all this group of people and where they're at in life and dealing with whatever it is they're dealing. But you're singing Ed in that moment as Andy is like, it's like you, you're a half time at the Super Bowl, man, you're just like everything, your whole body is into it. And it made me so happy. I just love that moment.
米夫林宇宙的大多数时候都在苦苦挣扎的。嗯，我很喜欢这一集的结尾。我想我重看了，不知道，三四遍。它让我开心。它让我的心感到快乐。达里尔在钢琴上弹奏梅西·格雷的《I Try》，而安迪则在大声放歌。你有一个蒙太奇，展示了这群人在生活中所处的位置，以及他们如何应对他们正在处理的任何事情。但你在那一刻唱歌，埃德，安迪就像，这就像你，超级碗的中场秀，老兄，你就像你整个人都投入其中了。这让我太开心了。我就是喜欢那个时刻。
Randy told us that the original song for the end was My Heart Will Go On, the Titanic song. That rings a bell. Yeah. He said you even had to go into a studio and record it. And he has like the only recording of it. What? Of it? Of you. We haven't heard it, but he said there is this impassioned version of you singing My Heart Will Go On and then they couldn't get the rights to it and they had to change
兰迪告诉我们，结尾原本的歌是《我心永恒》，《泰坦尼克号》的歌。这听起来耳熟。是的。他说你甚至不得不去录音室录制它。他拥有唯一的录音。什么？它的？你的。我们没听过，但他说有你充满激情地演唱《我心永恒》的版本，然后他们拿不到版权，不得不改变
it. I vaguely remember that, but I don't remember recording it or, but man, I want to hear that. I know. We'll get it for you from Randy. Yeah. He has a vault of pretty amazing things. Is there any moment from this episode for you that like stood out for Andy as like one of your favorite moments?
它。我依稀记得那件事，但我不记得录过，或者，但是老天，我想听听那个。我知道。我们会从兰迪那里帮你弄来。是的。他有一个相当神奇的东西的宝库。对你来说，这一集里有没有哪个时刻就像是安迪的最爱时刻之一，让你脱颖而出？
I think there's a lot of really cool stuff in this episode. The cold open is just so fun. That's a really special, special thing. And it's Andy kind of like, it's a rare moment of Andy just living in his skin with so much passion and self-confidence. And that's really, really cool. I think the, I was proud of how the, it's very short, but the musical, the solo. Joanna. Yeah. Yeah.
我认为这一集里有很多非常酷的东西。冷开场太有趣了。那是一个非常特别，特别的事情。而且这有点像安迪，这是安迪难得的一个时刻，他带着如此多的激情和自信活在自己的皮肤里。那真的，真的很酷。我认为，我为这部音乐剧的独唱感到骄傲，虽然它非常短。乔安娜。是的。是的。
I put a lot of work into that and was really proud of how that turned out. Narratively, the Aaron stuff is, is really poignant. I thought that was really sweet. You know, Aaron is just so detached and so like, but it's, but she's clearly tapping into some longing for Andy by showing up and then, and then him kind of getting it at the end and just being like, this, yeah, this is not, not good. Yeah. I loved Andy's earnestness when Aaron had to take the babysitting job when he's like, I get it. It's a huge opportunity.
我在那上面花了很多功夫，对它的结果感到非常自豪。叙事上，艾琳的剧情，非常凄美。我觉得那真的很甜。你知道的，艾琳是如此冷漠，而且如此像，但它是，但她通过出现显然在挖掘对安迪的一些渴望，然后，然后他在最后明白了这一点并就像，这，是的，这不，不好。是的。我喜欢安迪在艾琳不得不接受保姆工作时的认真劲儿，当时他说，我懂的。这是一个巨大的机会。
Yeah. Oh my gosh. He's checking his phone backstage. One of the most brilliant. Okay. So this is actually funny because I was saying before how I generally think that performing badly is a cheap joke. Like if it's, if you're performing, you know, in a performance context and you're doing it badly on purpose. I don't like that usually, but the tag of this episode. Oh my gosh. Of Michael Scott, do we? Lawn Order.
是的。哦，天哪。他在后台检查他的手机。最 brilhante 的之一。好吧。所以这其实很有趣，因为我之前说过，我通常认为糟糕的表演是一个廉价的笑话。就像如果你在表演，你知道的，在表演语境中，而你故意演得很烂。我通常不喜欢那样，但是这一集的标签。哦，天哪。迈克尔·斯科特的，我们演吗？《法律与秩序》。
Lawn Order. An entire episode. So badly. As a monologue. So badly. It's so funny. Like I, I watched that four or five times. It's just, it's priceless. But how many people could do that and sell it? But Steve, you know, because that, I believed it. I believed every second that that's how Michael Scott would have done it. 100%. And, you know, Steve almost never broke on, I mean, he very rarely broke. And I was
《法律与秩序》。整整一集。演得太烂了。作为独白。演得太烂了。太搞笑了。就像我，我看了四五遍。简直是无价之宝。但有多少人能做到这一点并把它卖出去呢？但是史蒂夫，你知道的，因为那个，我相信了。我相信迈克尔·斯科特会那样做的每一秒钟。100%。而且，你知道的，史蒂夫几乎从不笑场，我的意思是，他极少笑场。而我当时
watching that being like, he had to be cracking himself up. Like this was, there were, I guarantee you there were a few times he broke, you know. When he was slinging, I don't know what, was it a belt or a sash or something as the lady? Yeah. I know he broke doing that. I know he had to have cracked himself up. Or singing the theme song. Like, I just, oh my God. I know. Priceless. Do you guys, I'm curious, like we made so many office episodes and, and it's
看着那个心想：他肯定把自己逗乐了。就像这个，我向你保证有几次他笑场了，你知道的。当他挥舞着，我不知道是什么，是一条皮带还是一条腰带作为那个女士？是的。我知道他做那个时笑场了。我知道他一定把自己逗笑了。或者唱主题曲。就像，我，哦，天哪。我知道。无价之宝。你们，我很好奇，我们制作了那么多办公室剧集，而且，这
really funny to me the way fans understand the episodes as these like very tight, coherent stories. Whereas I find that from our perspective as the actors in looking at these stories from a production standpoint, it takes us a week to shoot a half hour episode. And then we go right into the next week of another episode. And when you look back on it, it's just kind of this wash of work, right? And I don't, for me, it's very hard to kind of remember the specifics of episodes and the specifics of like what was in what episode. And I mean, you guys have been really kind of studying them. So it's probably more front of mind for you. But, but I, I am, I'm, I found this going back and watching this episode
对我来说非常有趣，粉丝们理解这些剧集的方式是把它们当作这些非常紧凑、连贯的故事。然而我发现，从我们作为演员的角度来看，从制作的角度来看待这些故事，拍一集半小时的剧需要我们花一周时间。然后我们马上进入下一周的另一集。当你回顾它时，它只是一种工作的洗礼，对吧？而且我，对我来说，很难记住剧集的细节以及什么在什么剧集里的细节。我的意思是，你们一直在研究它们。所以这对你们来说可能更是当务之急。但是，但，我，我发现回顾并观看这一集
like it did trigger a lot of memories, but it also was a little frustrating kind of realizing that what I don't remember. And there's certain scenes, I don't know if you have this experience watching episodes of the office. All the time. Where you're like, I don't remember shooting that. I don't remember. I don't even remember that day or what was going on. And sometimes it's because you have some crazy thing going on in your life. Or, but more often, I think it's just because you just don't remember every day at work. And I got a little heart sick kind of watching there were some, some
就像它确实触发了很多记忆，但也多少有点令人沮丧，意识到我记不得什么了。有些特定的场景，我不知道你在看办公室剧集时是否有这种经历。一直都有。你会想，我不记得拍过那个了。我不记得了。我甚至不记得那一天或者当时发生了什么。有时是因为你的生活中有一些疯狂的事情发生。或者，但更常见的是，我认为这只是因为你不可能记住工作的每一天。而且看着有些部分时我有点心碎，
parts of this episode where I was like, Oh boy, I wish I remembered like just, you know, that, that, that scene where we're all around the piano together, it's one of those rare scenes where almost everybody is like in a clump. And it's with positive energy, right? Usually it's usually it's like, you know, a meeting in the conference room. Yeah, it's all crazy. But like to have a moment where, where everyone's kind of in a good place and happy. It just, I remember watching that and thinking like, this is, this is so special. Like I love these people. I love these human beings. And it made me a little bit heart sick for the things I don't remember.
这一集的一部分，我心想：哦，天哪，我希望我能记住，哪怕只是，你知道的，那个我们所有人围着钢琴聚在一起的场景，那是罕见的几乎每个人都挤成一团的场景之一。而且带着积极的能量，对吧？通常它通常就像是，你知道的，会议室里的会议。是的，太疯狂了。但能有一个时刻，每个人都处于一个好地方并且快乐。我记得看着那个心想：这，这太特别了。我爱这些人。我爱这些人类。这让我对那些我不记得的事情感到有点心碎。
You're literally your character has the line at the end where you say in the finale, you wish that you knew you were in the good times when you were in them. Like that's literally what you're saying. It's true. Yeah. But I get it. It is true though, because you work every day and some days stand out and some days don't. It doesn't matter what your job is and acting is no different. But sometimes I don't know the show the way people know it when they can just sit down and watch it all the way
字面意义上你的角色在结局里有一句台词，你说你在结局里希望你在经历美好时光的时候就知道自己正在经历。就像这字面意思就是你说的。真的。是的。但我懂。这确实是真的，因为你每天都在工作，有些日子脱颖而出，有些日子则不然。不管你的工作是什么，演戏也没有什么不同。但有时候我并不像人们那样了解这部剧，当他们能够坐下来一直看到底
through. Right, right. And we, we crossboarded episodes. Sometimes we shot three days in one episode and two days in another episode. And it kind of becomes like when your kids mix all the play dough together, you know, and you get that one big play dough mound. I don't know. That's not very articulate. I liked that metaphor. I do too.
的时候。对，对。而且我们，我们交叉拍摄剧集。有时我们在三里拍一集，在两里拍另一集。它有点像当你把所有的橡皮泥混在一起的时候，你知道的，你就得到了那个大橡皮泥堆。我不知道。这表达得不太好。我喜欢那个隐喻。我也喜欢。
I feel like every conference room scene is one memory in my head. So many of these episodes I hadn't seen since we filmed them. Crazy. But I'm so thankful for like a wonderful thing that we have. Amen. Yeah. And when I do catch an episode here and there, it is like just hanging out with old friends. Yeah. It's just awesome. I don't think I ever lost the feeling of excitement walking on to set about what was going to happen. Like, what are these hilarious, wonderful people going
我觉得每一个会议室场景在我的脑海里都是一段记忆。其中很多剧集自从我们拍完之后我就没看过。太疯狂了。但我非常感谢我们拥有的这段美好经历。阿门。是的。每当我在这里或那里看到一集时，那就像是和老朋友一起出去玩。是的。太棒了。我想我从来没有失去那种走进片场对将要发生的事情感到兴奋的感觉。就像，这些搞笑、美妙的人今天会做些什么来
to do to surprise me today? And I can, and like you were saying, conference room scenes, like all of us getting in there just being like, there's something funny is going to happen. Like somebody's going to do something. We all have the script. We know what we're going to say. But it's still like, I can't wait to see how BJ does this line or I can't wait to see how Oscar does this line. And then, you know, take after take. It's just so warm and funny. And there are of course times that you get run down and you get tired and cranky. But I always, always would walk into that soundstage like feeling excited and real and remembering back. I mean,
给我惊喜？而且我能，就像你说的，会议室场景，就像我们所有人进到里面，就好像，总会有搞笑的事情发生。就像某人会做点什么。我们都有剧本。我们知道我们要说什么。但它依然像，我迫不及待地想看BJ怎么演这句台词，或者我迫不及待地想看奥斯卡怎么演这句台词。然后，你知道的，一条又一条。它是如此温馨和搞笑。当然也有你筋疲力尽、又累又暴躁的时候。但我总是，总是会带着兴奋和真实的感觉走进那个录音棚，并回忆过去。我的意思是，
years, how many years? I worked on the show less than you guys, but seven years. Almost as long. Almost as long. And just always walking on that stage was, was so like, just, just so fun. And like, what's going to happen? Well, Ed, before we let you go, can you tell us a little bit about your music? Are you performing anywhere with your banjo? Are you still doing the bluegrass situation? Yeah. So the bluegrass situation.com is still very much alive and well. And that's a, that's
几年，多少年？我在这部剧工作的时间比你们短，但也有七年。几乎一样长。几乎一样长。而且总是走进那个舞台，是如此的像，仅仅是，如此有趣。并且，会发生什么呢？好吧，埃德，在我们让你离开之前，你能跟我们多聊聊你的音乐吗？你还在带着你的班卓琴到处演出吗？你还在做蓝草音乐吗？是的。所以thebluegrasssituation.com依然非常充满生机。那是
just kind of a roots and folk bluegrass music kind of community news blog hub. And that's great. I have pulled back from performing a lot in the last couple of years. I had kids and I'm just kind of focused elsewhere, but I still play all the time, especially for my kids because they're a captive audience and they can't walk away. And, and I'm eager to start getting back out there. Yeah. I've been, I've been playing a lot and I'm starting to kind of get more serious about practicing and, and, and rehearsing, but there's not much going on in the professional space at this point. Except Rutherford Falls.
一种根源、民谣和蓝草音乐的社区新闻博客中心。那太棒了。我在过去几年里减少了很多演出。我有了孩子，我只是把精力集中在别处，但我仍然一直在弹奏，尤其是为我的孩子们，因为他们是受众，无法走开。而且，我渴望开始重新出去演出。是的。我一直在，我一直在弹奏，而且我开始对练习和排练变得更认真了，但在专业领域目前没有太多事情发生。除了《拉瑟福德瀑布》。
Oh yes, of course. Season two is out now on Chicago. Yes. Yes, indeed. Rutherford Falls season two. Very, very proud of this show, which I co-created with an amazing showrunner, Sierra Teller Ornelas and Michael Scherr, who office fans know well. That's going on. We love it. We love it. Ed, I want to say two things to you. Banjo Kids Album. Banjo.
哦，是的，当然。第二季现在正在芝加哥上映。是的。是的，确实如此。第二季《拉瑟福德瀑布》。为这部剧感到非常非常骄傲，我和一位出色的剧集运作人西拉·特勒·奥内拉斯以及办公室粉丝们熟知的迈克尔·舒尔共同创作了它。正在播出。我们很喜欢。我们很喜欢。埃德，我想对你两件事。班卓琴儿童专辑。班卓琴。
Right? That is, that has crossed my mind. I've been writing a lot of music lately and I think I'm going to, I just, I think. I would have loved that when Isabel was little because, you know, I, I don't know. I had all the same songs that everyone had had forever. And anytime there was a new kids song that had any kind of a fun tune, oh my gosh, I got so excited. All right. All right. That might be the push I needed to get it done.
对吧？那，那个我考虑过。我最近写了很多音乐，我想我打算，我只是，我想。如果伊莎贝尔小的时候有那个，我会很喜欢的，因为，你知道的，我，我不知道。我拥有每个人永远拥有的所有相同的歌。每当有一首带有任何有趣曲调的新儿歌时，哦，天哪，我就会兴奋得不行。好吧。好吧。那可能是促成它所需的推动力。
Okay. All right. Ed, we love you so much. Thank you so much for being here. Thank you for coming in the studio. Yes. Ed is in here. You guys are sitting next to us. This is the table. Yes, we're here. He's next to you. Thanks so much for having me. It's just so good to see you guys. It's wonderful. Warm my heart. I love you. Well, we're going to take a break. We're
好的。好吧。埃德，我们太爱你啦。非常感谢你来到这里。谢谢你走进录音室。是的。埃德在这里。你们坐在我们旁边。这就是那张桌子。是的，我们在这。他就在你旁边。非常感谢邀请我。很高兴见到你们。太棒了。温暖了我的心。我爱你们。好吧，我们要休息一下。我们要
going to walk Ed out and then we'll be back to break down this episode. Angela, I'm just going to be happy all day now because we got to hang out with Ed. I know. We should tell you guys we've actually been chatting with him for like an hour. We talked to Ed for two hours. Yeah. I didn't want him to leave me either and we did finally have to let him go. Let him go.
把埃德送出去，然后我们会回来剖析这一集。安吉拉，我今天一整天都会很高兴，因为我们和埃德一起玩了。我知道。我们应该告诉你们，我们其实跟他聊了一个小时。我们跟埃德聊了两个小时。是的。我也不想让他离开，我们最后不得不让他走。让他走。
Yeah. We have to finish this episode. Yeah. Also during our break, we reached out to Randy and you guys, he's sending Cassie the audio file of Ed singing. My heart will go on right now. We are going to play it at the end of the episode. I can't wait. Yes. Definitely stick around to hear this. We heard it and it is truly, truly amazing. Like I got chills.
是的。我们得完成这一集。是的。同样在我们的休息期间，我们联系了兰迪，你们知道吗，他现在就把埃德唱歌的音频文件发给卡西了。我心永恒，就是现在。我们将在这一集结束时播放它。我等不及了。是的。一定要留下来听听这个。我们听过了，它真的，真的太棒了。就像我都起鸡皮疙瘩了。
I know. It was kind of a moment. We're going to play the whole entire song. Ed gave us his permission. Enjoy, but stick to the end. It's there. It'll be at the end. Okay. Let's start breaking down this episode. We talked about this a little bit. This episode opens with this fantastic cold open, this performance of a musical number from Sweeney Todd surprises the whole bullpen. Yeah.
我知道。这真是一个时刻。我们要播放整首歌。埃德给了我们许可。尽情享受吧，但要坚持到最后。它就在那儿。它会在最后。好的。让我们开始剖析这一集。我们稍微讨论了一下这个。这一集以这个精彩的冷开场开场，对《理发师陶德》中音乐剧唱段的表演让整个大办公室都大吃一惊。是的。
Michael is like, oh my gosh, I auditioned for this. When did the cast list go up? What part did I get? How clueless is Michael? We got a fan catch from Carrie F in Japan. Who said, when Michael asks about the cast list, look at Creed's face in the background. It is amazing. And I feel like everyone should pause to see it. Oh my goodness. Did you look at it? I did. What's he doing?
迈克尔就像，哦，天哪，我为这个试镜了。演员名单什么时候贴出来的？我得到了什么角色？迈克尔有多么一无所知？我们收到了来自日本的卡莉·F的粉丝截图。她说，当迈克尔询问演员名单时，看背景里克里德的脸。太棒了。我觉得每个人都应该暂停看一下。哦，天哪。你看它了吗？看了。他在干嘛？
He, it's hard to explain, but it is a great look. He looks almost like he's responsible for not casting Michael. Like, I don't want to discuss, it was his decision. It's amazing. All right. I have to go check that out. Thanks, Carrie. I was so impressed with this opening musical number. I really thought we should hear these guys. Oh, let's do it. Andy? Yes.
他，这很难解释，但这是一个伟大的表情。他看起来几乎就像他是没让迈克尔入选的罪魁祸首一样。就像，我不想讨论，那是他的决定。太棒了。好吧，我得去看看。谢谢卡莉。我对这个开场音乐剧唱段印象深刻。我真的觉得我们应该听听这些家伙的歌声。哦，我们来听吧。安迪？是的。
Did you write this? No. Who did? Stephen Sondheim. Who is Stephen Sondheim? Stephen Sondheim. Who is he? Swing your razor by.
这是你写的吗？不是。那是谁写的？斯蒂芬·桑德海姆。谁是斯蒂芬·桑德海姆？斯蒂芬·桑德海姆。他是谁？挥舞你的剃刀。
Sweetie, hold it to the sky. Sweetie, blows a lot of bells to our lives. What the hell is happening? We had a fan question from Miriam Ellen Utah who wanted to know, how much did NBC pay in royalties for Sweeney Todd? Miriam said typical grand rights can cost a small high school production thousands of dollars. What did you guys pay? Well, I checked with Randy Cordray, of course, and he said this really was a huge deal. Quote, we basically had to produce a full blown community theater production of Sweeney Todd embedded
甜蜜的，把它举向天空。甜蜜的，吹响了许多通往我们生活的钟声。这到底是怎么回事？我们有一个来自犹他州米里亚姆·埃伦的粉丝问题，她想知道，NBC为《理发师陶德》支付了多少版税？米里亚姆说典型的大版权可能会花费一所小型高中制作数千美元。你们付了多少？嗯，我当然跟兰迪·科德雷核实过了，他说这真的是一笔大买卖。原话是：“我们基本上不得不制作一个嵌入在办公室完整一集中的《理发师陶德》完整社区剧院制作，而且谈判音乐版权很复杂。”他说埃里克·科尔根，我们的后期制作人，联系了环球电视音乐总监凯莉·德鲁滕以获得同步版权。这意味着
into a full blown episode of the office and negotiating the music rights was complicated. He said Eric Colgen, our post producer, contacted the Universal Television Music Supervisor, Kerry Druten, about getting the sync rights. That meant that we were allowed to sing the song ourselves. We weren't going to like play a recorded soundtrack. Yeah, there's all these layers to it. But we also had to get something called grand rights because we were going to air it on television. Oh, there's a difference between just doing it on a stage and then committing it to television
我们被允许自己唱这首歌。我们不会播放录制的原声带。是的，这里面有很多层面的东西。但我们还不得不获得所谓的“大版权”，因为我们要把它在电视上播出。哦，仅仅在舞台上表演和把它永远致力于电视之间是有区别的。
forever. Steve and Sonheim had to sign off. They had to send him our script. Really? Mm-hmm. He read our script. He read Andy's play. Oh my gosh. Guess what?
斯蒂芬·桑德海姆不得不签字。他们不得不把我们的剧本送给他。真的吗？嗯哼。他读了我们的剧本。他读了安迪的戏剧。哦，天哪。你猜怎么着？
What? He loved it. Oh, he gave us his blessing. Ultimately, we ended up paying $100,000 and we got the rights to sing four songs. And that's how we did it. Wow. I have a fan question from Sarah L in San Antonio, Texas. What's up, Sarah? Hi, Sarah. Where did the singers come from for this episode? Sarah, I love this question. We'll tell you
什么？他很喜欢。哦，他给予了我们祝福。最终，我们支付了10万美元，我们获得了演唱四首歌的版权。这就是我们做到的。哇。我有一个来自得克萨斯州圣安东尼奥市的莎拉·L的粉丝问题。怎么了，莎拉？嗨，莎拉。这集的歌手是哪来的？莎拉，我喜欢这个问题。我们会告诉你
all about it. Yeah, all the singers were cast by our casting director, Alison Jones. And our director for this episode was John Scott. Before he directed the office, he had directed episodes of Glee. And he'd also worked as a camera operator and cinematographer. So this kind of made him perfect because he knew how to blend musical performance and documentary style shooting. This is the only episode of the office that he directed. And thank goodness, we got him for it. I know. He's a prolific director. If you look him up, he's just done everything.
关于它的一切。是的，所有的歌手都是由我们的选角导演艾莉森·琼斯选角的。我们这一集的导演是约翰·斯科特。在他导演《办公室》之前，他曾导演过《欢乐合唱团》的剧集。他还曾担任过摄像师和摄影师。所以这使他堪称完美，因为他知道如何将音乐表演和纪录片风格的拍摄融为一体。这是他导演的唯一一集《办公室》。感谢上帝，我们请到了他。我知道。他是一位多产的导演。如果你查阅他的资料，他几乎什么都做过。
We also hired a musical supervisor for this episode who Randy called a musical genius. His name was Nathan Wang. He prepped all of the musical background tracks, attended all rehearsals, and he sat in on the auditions with Alison Jones and John Scott. So the three of them found all of our singers. Yes. And Nathan, if you listen to this, Randy could not say enough wonderful things about you. He just went on and on about how important you were for this episode. Yes. Randy also told us that this cold open sequence was choreographed by Mary Ann Kellogg. You guys remember she did the lip dub and here were the performers. Kelly Ebsere played the
我们还为这一集雇佣了一位音乐总监，兰迪称他为音乐天才。他的名字叫南森·王。他准备了所有的音乐背景音轨，参加了所有的排练，并与艾莉森·琼斯和约翰·斯科特一起参加了试镜。所以他们三个找到了我们所有的歌手。是的。南森，如果你听到这个，兰迪对你赞不绝口。他滔滔不绝地讲述你对这一集有多么重要。是的。兰迪还告诉我们，这个冷开场序列是由玛丽安·凯洛格编舞的。你们还记得她制作了对口型视频，这些是表演者。
beggar lady. Maxwell Glick played Tobias. Heather Marie Marsden played Mrs. Lovett. David Kirk Grant played castmate number two. Erica Hanrahan Ball played Joanna. Harry Murphy played Judge Turpin. Randy Gaia played Pirelli. And Michael Tuba Heatherton played Beatle. What a fantastic group. And lady, how fun was it to see Tuba? I know. I know we should tell everybody who he is because he appeared on the office several times. We even got a fan catch from Rob B. in Los Angeles, California, who said, ladies, I think you need a Tuba tracker. Oh, a Tuba tracker. This episode marks the first appearance
凯利·埃布塞里饰演乞丐夫人。麦克斯韦·格利克饰演托比亚斯。希瑟·玛丽·马斯登饰演洛维特夫人。大卫·柯克·格兰特饰演剧组成员二号。埃里卡·汉拉汉·鲍尔饰演乔安娜。哈里·墨菲饰演图尔平法官。兰迪·盖亚饰演皮雷利。还有迈克尔·图巴·希瑟顿饰演比尔。多么棒的团队啊。而且，女士们，看到图巴有多好玩？我知道。我知道我们应该告诉大家他是谁，因为他在《办公室》里出现过好几次。我们甚至收到了来自加利福尼亚州洛杉矶的罗布·B的粉丝截图，他说，女士们，我觉得你们需要一个图巴追踪器。哦，一个图巴追踪器。这一集标志着
of Michael Tuba Heatherton in the series. And he reprises this role in a deleted scene from season eight, episode 13, jury duty, where he pretends to be a police officer only to be recognized by Daryl as a member of Andy's play. I look forward to that deleted scene, lady. But we will also see Tuba in the seminar as an attendee of Andy's seminar. And we're going to see two of Tuba's clown headshots in Roseanne's talent agency in season nine. And finally, we're going to see him as the minister in season nine, the farm. And in the finale, marrying Dwight and Angela, he's just like Nelson Franklin. He is because he played multiple roles or maybe the same. Maybe he's a man who has many jobs, yeah, like the
迈克尔·图巴·希瑟顿在剧中的首次亮相。他在第八季第十三集《陪审团义务》的删减片段中再次扮演了这个角色，在那里他假装是一名警察，结果却被达里尔认出是安迪戏剧的成员。我期待那个删减片段，女士。但我们也会在研讨会上看到图巴作为安迪研讨会的参与者。我们还将在第九季罗珊的经纪公司里看到图巴的两个小丑大头照。最后，我们将在第九季《农场》中看到他担任牧师。在结局中，为主持德怀特和安吉拉的婚礼，他就像尼尔森·富兰克林一样。他是，因为他扮演了多个角色，或者也许是同一个角色。也许他是一个有很多工作的男人，是的，就像《吉尔莫女孩》里的角色柯克一样。他到处工作。我从来没看过《吉尔莫女孩》。哇，真的吗？是的。哦，他们说话语速真的很快。真的吗？是的，那是那个特点，对话。
character Kirk on Gilmore Girls. He worked everywhere. I have never seen Gilmore Girls. Whoa, really? Yeah. Oh, they talk real fast. They do? Yeah, that was the thing, the dialogue. It comes out very, very fast. Oh, just a style choice? Yes. I don't think I... And you had to say your lines exactly as written. I would not do very well. This is not the show. It's good. You were not cast on it. No, I was not. Well, Robby from Los Angeles wants to know is it just a happy coincidence that Tuba was cast in so many one-off roles on the office, or is there another reason? There is another reason. First of all, Tuba's amazing. We love him. In addition to being extremely talented, Tuba was also married to our amazing script
出来得非常非常快。哦，只是一种风格选择？是的。我不认为我……而且你必须一字不差地按写好的台词说。我可能做不好。这不是这个剧。很好。你没被选上。不，我没有。好吧，来自洛杉矶的罗布比想知道，图巴在《办公室》里被选入这么多客串角色，这仅仅是一个快乐的巧合，还是有其他原因？有其他原因。首先，图巴太棒了。我们爱他。除了极具才华之外，图巴还嫁给了我们出色的剧本
supervisor, Theta. Yeah. And Tuba was an actor. He was a professional clown. Just an amazing person. Well, let's get into this episode because Andy has two comps for closing night of his show for Erin and her Gabe. And he finds out Gabe isn't going. He didn't think anyone else was going to go. How happy is Andy? He is so happy until it looks like nobody else is coming. Like... Yeah. Jim and Pam's babysitter fell through. Michael's a real sour. He doesn't want to go. There was a series of talking heads here in the shooting draft, and several people share their thoughts on musical theater. Oh, yeah. Yes. I really want to share with you what Stanley has to say and his feelings about standing ovations. I'll be there, but
总监瑟塔。是的。而且图巴是个演员。他是个职业小丑。简直是个了不起的人。好吧，让我们进入这一集，因为安迪有两张他演出的闭幕夜门票，是给艾琳和她的盖布的。然后他发现盖布不去了。他以为没别人会去了。安迪有多高兴？他太高兴了，直到看起来好像没别人来。就像……是的。吉姆和帕姆的保姆泡汤了。迈克尔是个十足的扫兴鬼。他不想去。这里在拍摄初稿中有一系列谈话头。哦，是的。是的。我真的很想分享斯坦利要说的话以及他对起立鼓掌的感受。我会去的，但
do not expect to stand a novation. I am sick of going to shows and feeling like I need to stand when the show isn't that good. You hear me, Steve Harvey? What? He's throwing shade at Steve Harvey? I love this talking head. I did, too. I've been to shows where everyone's standing up at the end. It's almost like we stand up at the end of every show. And then you feel bad if you don't. Yeah. And I had a little Stanley. I was like, well, how are they going to know when it's a real standing ovation? If we stand at the end of all of them, it's sort of like, you know, the participation prize. But then I know what it takes to put on a theater production. And you're like, you better stand up. We worked
别指望起立鼓掌。我厌倦了去看演出，并且觉得当演出其实没那么好时我需要起立。你听到了吗，史蒂夫·哈维？什么？他在内涵史蒂夫·哈维？我喜欢这个谈话头。我也喜欢。我去过那种最后每个人都站起来的演出。这感觉几乎就像我们在每场演出的最后都会站起来。然后如果你不站，你就会觉得内疚。是的。我有了一点斯坦利的心态。我会想，好吧，他们怎么知道什么时候才是真正的起立鼓掌？如果我们对所有演出都在最后起立，这有点像，你知道的，参与奖。但随后我知道办一场戏剧制作需要付出什么。你会想，你最好站起来。我们付出了
our butts off. Yeah. Just getting a show off the ground and from beginning to end, stand on up. I feel both ways. This talking head really made me laugh. And then also now when you rewatch this episode, at the end, when they give a standing ovation, it cuts to Stanley and he's got the biggest grump face because he has to now stand and he's really annoyed. You know what? It's funny. I know they cut the talking head, but everything about that shot of him like doing the obligatory standing ovation told me the whole story. Yep. I knew all his feelings about it. Well, Lady Dwight is not going to go because the last time he went to the theater, a man dressed as a cat sat on his lap. I feel like Angela made him
全部心血。是的。仅仅是将一场演出从无到有地推向舞台，站起来吧。我两种感觉都有。这个谈话头真的让我大笑。而且现在当你重温这一集时，在最后，当他们起立鼓掌时，镜头切到斯坦利，他脸上带着最夸张的不满表情，因为他现在不得不站起来，而且他真的很恼火。你知道吗？有趣的是，我知道他们剪掉了谈话头，但关于他那种敷衍起立鼓掌的镜头的一切都告诉我了整个故事。是的。我知道他对此的所有感受。好吧，女士，德怀特不打算去，因为上次他去看戏时，一个扮成猫的男人坐在了他的大腿上。我觉得是安吉拉逼他
go to cats. Lady, we got so much mail from people. You did? Kobe S. from Wisconsin said, in my mind, I have come to believe that Dwight attended a local production of cats to appease Angela and I believe Andy was the cat who sat on Dwight's lap because in season five employee transfer, Andy dressed like a cat for the production of cats. Yes. I was so curious about that line that I went to the shooting draft to see if it said something like Dwight glances over at Angela. Angela rolls her eyes or something like that. It didn't, but I fully believe that Angela made him go to cats. I'm with you and Kobe S. Yes, Kobe. Guess who wants to go to the play? I know. Angela, I think this is proving the point that she
去看《猫》的。女士，我们收到了人们寄来的雪多信。是吗？来自威斯康星州的科比·S说，在我的脑海里，我开始相信德怀特为了安吉拉去看了当地的《猫》制作，而且我相信安迪就是那个坐在德怀特大腿上的猫，因为在第五季《员工调动》中，安迪为了制作《猫》而打扮成猫。是的。我对那句台词太好奇了，所以我去查了拍摄初稿，看看它是不是写着类似于“德怀特瞥了一眼安吉拉。安吉拉翻了个白眼”之类的话。并没有，但我完全相信是安吉拉逼他去看《猫》的。我和你以及科比·S同感。是的，科比。你猜谁想去看戏？我知道。安吉拉，我认为这证明了这一点，她
goes to musicals and she says she would like Dwight to take her and he's like, just just robe. Let's get to it basically. And she's like, uh-uh. No, no, no. You have to take me to the play to get the punch. I have a location alert for this scene. Yes, it's a new location. This is Dwight's office. Now that he's the owner of the building, this is his business manager office. Yes, and it's much nicer than his office at Dunder Mifflin. Yeah, that's true. He doesn't have. He's just part of a desk clump. Well, this was designed by Michael Gallenberg and built by Tim James and it existed over on our warehouse set. At four minutes, 28 seconds, did any of you guys notice the picture of the drone,
去看音乐剧，她说她想让德怀特带她去，而德怀特说，穿上长袍就行。基本上就是这样。而她说，不，不。你必须带我去戏剧演出才能得到印章。我为这个场景准备了一个取景地警报。是的，是一个新取景地。这是德怀特的办公室。既然他是这栋楼的老板，这就是他的物业经理办公室。是的，而且比他在唐德米夫林的办公室好得多。是的，没错。他不用。他只是办公桌群的一部分。好吧，这是迈克尔·加伦伯格设计的，蒂姆·詹姆斯建造的，它存在于我们的仓库布景上。在4分钟28秒时，你们有没有人注意到那个无人机的照片，
the predator drone, big picture? It's tilted. Yes, I did notice that. I was wondering why it was tilted. I figured it had to be on purpose because it's so obviously tilted. I went to the shooting draft to see and this is how it read. Dwight is in his building management office hanging a picture of a predator drone and Angela enters. Angela says, it's crooked. Dwight says, yes, and if I come back and it's straight, I'll know someone was here. Angela says, smart. And then she goes on to say, I want you to take me to the play this evening and the scene continues as it aired. Well, Dwight does agree to take her to the play but he's not wearing a cape, okay? This made me realize, does he always wear a cape
捕食者无人机，大照片？它是倾斜的。是的，我注意到了。我在想为什么它是倾斜的。我想这肯定是故意的，因为它太明显是倾斜的了。我去查了拍摄初稿，它是这样写的：德怀特在他的物业管理办公室里挂一张捕食者无人机的照片，安吉拉进来了。安吉拉说：“它是歪的。”德怀特说：“是的，如果我回来时它是直的，我就会知道有人来过。”安吉拉说：“真聪明。”然后她接着说：“我想让你今晚带我去那个戏剧演出。”然后场景如播出的那样继续。好吧，德怀特确实同意带她去戏剧演出，但他没穿斗篷，好吗？这让我意识到，他去戏剧演出总是穿斗篷吗？就像，他不会为了她做他通常的打扮。是的，她以前问过吗？
to plays? Like, he's not going to do his usual zhuzh for her. Yeah, has she asked in the past? And he wore a cape. Maybe to cats. Yes. Angela's going to have a talking head where she says, Dwight and I have a contractual agreement to procreate five times, plain and simple. And should he develop feelings for me? Well, that would be permissible under item seven C, clause two, so I would not object. So that little smile at the end that I do, I improvised. Oh. It wasn't in the shooting draft and they really liked it and they asked me to do it every time. Oh, I love when we would do things like that. I know. It was fun to see it again because I remembered all of a sudden all those memories came back.
而且他穿了斗篷。也许去《猫》的时候穿了。是的。安吉拉有一个谈话头，她说：“我和德怀特有一个生育五个孩子的契约协议，简单明了。如果他对我有感情？嗯，这在第7C条第2款下是允许的，所以我不会反对。”所以我在最后那个小微笑，是我即兴发挥的。哦。拍摄初稿里没有，他们真的很喜欢，并要求我每次都这样做。哦，我喜欢我们做这种事的时候。我知道。再次看到它很有趣，因为我突然想起了所有那些记忆。
I was like, oh yeah. We thought maybe she would give away a little bit of her true feelings just for a second. It would always just fill me with such pride as an actor if I was there performing for the director and the writer and I did something with something they'd written for me and they asked me to do it over and over again. Yeah, yeah. I was like, oh yeah. Oh yeah. I did it. I did it. I love it. Pam and Jim are in a pickle because they actually really want to go but they don't have a babysitter. Yes. Andy comes in the kitchen and asks them if they could just keep looking and Pam's like, yes, we will keep looking. There was a joint Jim and Pam talking head. Yes. About how much they love going
我心想：哦，是的。我们觉得也许她会稍微透露一点她真实的情感，哪怕就一秒钟。作为演员，如果我在导演和编剧面前表演，而且我用他们为我写的东西做了一些事情，他们还要求我一遍又一遍地这样做，这总是会让我充满自豪感。是的，是的。我心想：哦，是的。哦，是的。我做到了。我做到了。我喜欢它。吉姆和帕姆陷入了困境，因为他们其实真的很想去，但他们没有保姆。是的。安迪来到厨房问他们是否能继续找，而帕姆说，是的，我们会继续找的。这里有一个吉姆和帕姆的联合谈话头。是的。关于他们多么喜欢去
to musical theater. I know. I know. When Randy was giving us his insider info on this episode, for this scene he wrote, Jenna, you sound like you have a cold. Oh yeah. I did. I think I did have a cold. Yeah. Well, it's time for the show. The loose screw playhouse is buzzing. Yes. Everyone has made it. Yeah. Phyllis is wearing her fur stole and she's arrived with Bob Vance. Mm-hmm. Stanley has brought his mistress. Cynthia. Mm-hmm. There was a whole runner where Phyllis thinks Cynthia's hitting on Bob and she's ticked off. I loved it. I know. It's in deleted scenes. It's so good. We had a fan question from Aaron Y. in Springfield, Ohio. Where was the performance of Andy's play located? Well, this was a
看音乐剧。我知道。我知道。当兰迪向我们提供他关于这一集的内部消息时，对于这个场景他写道：“珍娜，听起来你感冒了。”哦，是的。我确实感冒了。是的。好吧，演出开始了。松螺丝剧场热闹非凡。是的。每个人都到了。是的。菲利斯戴着她的皮草披肩，和鲍勃·凡斯一起到了。嗯哼。斯坦利带了他的情妇。辛西娅。嗯哼。这里有一个整条支线剧情，菲利斯认为辛西娅在调戏鲍勃，她气炸了。我喜欢它。我知道。它在删减片段里。太棒了。我们收到了来自俄亥俄州斯普林菲尔德的亚伦·Y的粉丝问题。安迪戏剧的表演在哪里取景的？好吧，这其实
little bit of trickery. Mm-hmm. The exterior shot of the theater that you just see very briefly with no people in front of it. That was the Macha Theater in West Hollywood. We used an old stock photo of the theater and added graphics on top to say loose screw playhouse. But the whole interior, the lobby, backstage, the stage, that was the Assistance League Theater. We shot there for four days and our base camp was in a Sears parking lot that was nearby. Mm-hmm. Lady, I feel like there's a chance you went to Sears one day. Maybe at lunch. Sounds like you. I'm sure I did. Oh, I went there. I liked it. You just remember the memory of yourself going. And you got so excited. I remember this. I was
有点小把戏。嗯哼。你非常短暂地看到的那张剧院外观照片，前面没有人。那是西好莱坞的玛查剧院。我们使用了该剧院的一张旧库存照片，并在顶部添加了图形，写着“松螺丝剧场”。但整个内部，大堂，后台，舞台，那是援助同盟剧院。我们在那里拍了四天，我们的基地营在附近的一个西尔斯百货停车场。嗯哼。女士，我觉得你有一天去西尔斯百货的几率很大。也许在午餐时间。听起来像你。我确信我去了。哦，我去了。我挺喜欢的。你只记得你自己去的记忆。并且你那么激动。我记得这个。我当时
so excited. You know, it's not easy to find a Sears in Los Angeles, California. No, it's not. It's where I bought my first washer and dryer when I moved here. Yeah. And I had to go far into the valley to find a Sears. Yeah. My very first credit card was a Sears credit card. Really? That I applied for by myself. I was so excited. I had a credit card. But only for Sears. But only for Sears. Wow. My first pair of roller skates. I ordered out of a catalog because I'm 100 years old. We were living in Jakarta, Indonesia. We got the Sears catalog and I ordered a pair of roller skates. And eight months later, they were mine because it took forever to get anything overseas at that time. Well, listen, I don't
太激动了。你知道的，在加利福尼亚州洛杉矶找一家西尔斯百货可不容易。不，不容易。那是我搬到这里时买第一个洗衣机和烘干机的地方。是的。我不得不深入山谷去找一家西尔斯。是的。我的第一张信用卡是一张西尔斯信用卡。真的吗？我自己申请的。我太激动了。我有一张信用卡。但只能在西尔斯用。但只能在西尔斯用。哇。我的第一双旱冰鞋。我是从目录里订购的，因为我都100岁了。我们住在印度尼西亚雅加达。我们拿到了西尔斯目录，我订购了一双旱冰鞋。八个月后它们才是我的，因为当时海外运送任何东西都要花好长时间。好吧，听着，我不知道
know what Sears is like today, but back in ye olde days. Ye olde times. That's where you bought all of your appliances because they had wonderful warranties and great service. Yeah. Mm-hmm. Michael is going to arrive. And one of my favorite lines that teases up the best tag of any episode, I think, is an usher says, Hey, are you the guy that did the entire Law and Order episode for your audition? Mm-hmm. Oh, my gosh. The usher was played by Barbara Fisher. No relation. I think we should point out that Michael arrived with a giant bunch of helium balloons. Oh, yes. Yeah. That are going to become a problem later. Well, there was a deleted scene where he called to get flowers, but they were so expensive.
今天的西尔斯是什么样的，但在老时光。老时光。那是你购买所有家电的地方，因为它们有极好的保修和优质的服务。好的。嗯哼。迈克尔要到了。我想这是任何一集中最好的标签的预热，我最喜欢的台词之一，是一个引座员说：“嘿，你就是那个在试镜时演了整整一集《法律与秩序》的家伙吗？”嗯哼。哦，天哪。引座员由芭芭拉·费舍饰演。没有亲戚关系。我想我们应该指出，迈克尔带着一大束氦气球到了。哦，是的。是的。这后来会成为一个问题。好吧，有一个删减片段，他打电话去买花，但它们太贵了。
He pretended that he lost reception and hung up. And then he got balloons instead. And then he got balloons instead. Well, Andy is thrilled that everyone has shown up. But he notices the one person who isn't there is the only person he wanted to be there, which is Erin. Yeah. But she is who is babysitting for Jim and Pam. Listen, the 13-year-olds have cornered the market on babysitting. It's been a real tough industry for her to get into. Yeah. She has this whole talking head where she says she really needs to get into the babysitting game. And, lady, I did a deep dive on babysitting. Did you? I'm very curious. You know, my very first job was babysitting. I started babysitting when I was 14. What did you get per hour?
他假装信号不好然后挂断了。然后他买了气球来代替。然后他买了气球来代替。好吧，安迪看到大家都来了，激动不已。但他注意到唯一没来的人是他唯一想让她来的人，也就是艾琳。是的。但她正在为吉姆和帕姆当保姆。听着，13岁的小孩垄断了保姆市场。这对她来说是一个很难进入的真正艰难的行业。是的。她有一个完整的谈话头，她说她真的很想进入保姆游戏，而且，女士，我对保姆做了一次深入研究。是吗？我很好奇。你知道的，我的第一份工作就是当保姆。我14岁就开始当保姆了。你一小时赚多少钱？
Oh, my goodness. I can't remember. I got a dollar an hour. That's what I got. And if there were two or more children, I got $2 an hour. I just remember I babysat these twin boys who were so little. They were like, I don't know, five months old. And I look back and I'm like, what were they thinking, leaving these twins with me? I was so unqualified. But I did take good care of them. No one was injured on my watch. Yeah. My best friend and I, we shared a babysitting summer job for this family. They had three children all under the age of seven. The littlest was like 10 months old. I don't remember him walking. And I would do like Mondays and Wednesdays. She would do Tuesdays and Thursdays. And then
哦，天哪。我记不清了。我一小时赚一美元。我就是赚这个。如果有两个或更多的孩子，我一小时赚两美元。我只记得我照顾过这一对太小的双胞胎男孩。他们就像，我不知道，五个月大。我回想起来心想：他们怎么想的，把这两个双胞胎留给我？我太不称职了。但我确实把他们照顾得很好。在我的眼皮底下没有人受伤。是的。我和我最好的朋友，我们为这家人分享了一份暑期保姆工作。他们有三个七岁以下的孩子。最小的就像10个月大。我不记得他会走路。我会负责周一和周三。她负责周二和周四。然后
we would both babysit on Fridays. And I must have been 15. Yeah. I couldn't drive a car if something happened. Yes. I didn't have a cell phone. Nobody had a cell phone. Nobody had a cell phone. I think back on that time and I just think like, what did I do with that baby all day? I know. I mean, they all lived. So I guess I took care of them. I'm sure we did a good job. But looking back on it now, especially that we have kids, you're like, what? Yeah. It was bonkers. I know. Well, I did have a lot of energy and I do remember doing things like setting up a sprinkler in the backyard and we're all running through it. And oh, I remember one time my baby sat this little girl and I decided we were going
我们俩在周五一起当保姆。我当时一定15岁。是的。如果发生什么事我不会开车。是的。我没有手机。没有人有手机。没有人有手机。我回想那个时候，我只是在想：我整天带着那个婴儿做了什么？我知道。我是说，他们都活下来了。所以我猜我照顾好他们了。我确信我们做得很出色。但现在回想起来，特别是我们有了孩子之后，你会想：什么？是的。太荒唐了。我知道。好吧，我确实有很多精力，我确实记得做一些事情，比如在后院设置一个洒水器，我们都在里面跑来跑去。哦，我记得有一次我照顾一个小女孩，我决定我们要
to make our own newspaper. I had a lot of energy. See, we were great babysitters. What's your deep dive say? Well, listen, according to mom news daily, the average cost of a babysitter nationwide right now is around $15 an hour. And then parents.com tracked the average hourly rate for a babysitter in every state. Oh, state by state. What's it for California? Because Isabel said she wants to start babysitting this summer. California is pretty good. What is it? It's around $17 an hour. An hour? Mm hmm. Wow. In Pennsylvania, it's $15. $15 an hour. The most expensive was New York at just over $18 an hour. Hmm. The least expensive was Louisiana at $12.49 an hour. But listen, no matter what state your baby
自己做一份报纸。我当时精力很旺盛。看，我们是伟大的保姆。你的深入研究说了什么？好吧，听着，根据“妈妈新闻日”网站的数据，现在全国保姆的平均费用大约是每小时15美元。然后父母网追踪了每个州保姆的平均每小时费率。哦，按州来看。加利福尼亚州是多少？因为伊莎贝尔说她想今年夏天开始当保姆。加利福尼亚州相当不错。是多少？大约是每小时17美元。每小时？嗯哼。哇。在宾夕法尼亚州，是15美元。每小时15美元。最贵的是纽约，刚过每小时18.美元。嗯。最便宜的是路易斯安那州，每小时12.49美元。但听着，无论你在哪个州带
sitting in, all of the rates are well above the federal minimum wage of $7.25. So this got me curious. Started looking up minimum wages. Okay. Because a lot of states have adopted higher minimum wages. For example, the minimum wage in Arkansas is $11. In Maine, it's $12.75. But there are many states who do not have a state minimum wage and instead they just rely on that $7.25. The minimum wage in Pennsylvania is $7.25. And this would have been true even at the time that this episode was filmed in 2010. Because the last time that we had a federal minimum wage increase was in 2007. This episode was filmed in 2010. So the minimum wage was $7.25. It is very likely that Erin was going to earn more than that. The bottom
孩子，所有的费率都远高于7.25美元的联邦最低工资。这让我很好奇。开始查找最低工资。好的。因为许多州已经通过了更高的最低工资。例如，阿肯色州的最低工资是11美元。在缅因州，是12.75美元。但有许多州没有州最低工资，而是仅仅依靠7.25美元。宾夕法尼亚州的最低工资是7.25美元。而且在2010年拍摄这一集时，这也是真的。因为我们最后一次联邦最低工资上调是在2007年。这一集拍摄于2010年。所以最低工资是7.25美元。艾琳的收入很有可能高于这个数字。我所有研究的底线是
line of all my research is that babysitting is almost always going to earn you more than either the federal or your state minimum wage. And Erin was right to want to get into the side hustle. Mm-hmm. Babysitting. Babysitting. Well, the play is starting and there's an important piece of information that is going to send Michael in a huge spiral. Oh, it's so great. Daryl says, hey, that's my plumber. Michael's like, uh-uh-uh-uh. No, no, no. The guy playing Sweeney Todd, he's a ringer. He's like a world-class actor. Daryl's like, nope, it's in the bio. That is my plumber. He's never even been in a play. They discovered him doing karaoke. Michael's like, are you kidding me? And then Daryl has one of my
，当保姆几乎总是能让你赚到比联邦或你的州最低工资更多的钱。而且艾琳想要进入这个副业是对的。嗯哼。当保姆。当保姆。好吧，戏剧开始了，有一个重要的信息会让迈克尔陷入巨大的螺旋式崩溃。哦，太棒了。达里尔说：“嘿，那是我的水管工。”迈克尔就像，“呃-哈-呃-哈。不，不，不。演理发师陶德的那个人，他是个高手。他就像个世界级的演员。”达里尔说：“不，简历上写着。那是我的水管工。他甚至从来没演过戏。他们在卡拉OK时发现了他的。”迈克尔就像：“你在开玩笑吧？”然后达里尔有一句我
favorite lines in the episode. He goes, shh, if we don't listen to the overture, we won't recognize the musical themes when they come back later. I loved that, too. At seven minutes and 10 seconds, I want to give a shout out to our sideline musicians. So we talked with Ed about how everybody was singing live. The music was actually not performed live. That was a playback soundtrack that had been prepared by Nathan Wang, our musical supervisor. But we have some musicians pretending to play all the music. They were Kevin Roberts, who was our keyboardist and conductor. Trey Balfour, who was our percussionist. Marina Menukian, who was the violinist. And Tom Evans was our flutist. Flutist? Flutist. Is a flutist
最喜欢的台词。他说：“嘘，如果我们不听序曲，等会儿音乐主题再现时我们就认不出来了。”我也很喜欢那个。在7分10秒时，我要向我们的旁台音乐家们致敬。我们和埃德谈过大家是怎么现场唱歌的。音乐其实不是现场演奏的。那是我们的音乐总监南森·王准备的伴奏音轨。但我们有一些音乐家假装在演奏所有的音乐。他们是凯文·罗伯茨，我们的键盘手兼指挥。特雷·巴尔弗，我们的打击乐手。玛丽娜·梅努基安，小提琴手。还有汤姆·埃文斯，我们的长笛手。长笛手（Flutist）？长笛手（Fluter）？Flutist是一个flutist吗？Flutist就是flutist。听起来像flutus，就像，你知道的，那个盘子。是flutus。为什么他们不是fluter？我不知道。
a flutist? A flutist is a flutist. It sounds like flutus, like, you know, the dish. It's a flutus. Why aren't they a flutist? I don't know. What's wrong with why are we confusing it? Why are we changing all the letters? It's probably a ye olde, timey reference that we held on to for no reason. Well, okay. Our flutus in his hammock was playing the flute. How about that? The show is well underway. And you know what? Andy's crushing it. He really is. He's singing his solo, Joanna. I mean, Stanley is sleeping, but Jim and Pam are impressed. So is Dwight. Dwight is kind of like nudging the guy next to him like, hey, I know that guy. Angela's going to get gum on her seat. Gross. She's got to leave.
有什么问题，我们为什么要搞混？这可能是个老时光的引用，我们毫无理由地保留了下来。好吧，好吧。我们的长笛手在吊床里吹着长笛。这样如何？演出正在顺利进行。你知道吗？安迪表现惊艳。他真的是。他在唱他的独唱曲《乔安娜》。我是说，斯坦利在睡觉，但吉姆和帕姆印象深刻。德怀特也是。德怀特有点像在用手肘碰旁边的人，就像：“嘿，我认识那家伙。”安吉拉的座位上沾了口香糖。真恶心。她得离开。
Is she going to get gum on her seat? She has to change. Yeah, she does because it's gross. Her body has touched some gum that was on a seat. Dwight says, you know what? I'm not going to tell you what happened while you're gone. He refuses. Do we have a new slash old tech alert? What is it? Kelly's going to ask Ryan for the time and he's going to show her a clock on his iPad. We had a fan mail flurry about that iPad, Angela. Ella Ward from Dallas, Texas and many others said, when Michael asked Andy in the beginning how long the play is, Andy says it's an hour and 45 minutes and it starts at 8pm sharp, meaning it should be over at 9.45. Maybe 10 o'clock with an intermission. But later in the episode
她要在座位上沾上口香糖吗？她得换一下。是的，她必须换，因为这很恶心。她的身体碰到了座位上的一块口香糖。德怀特说：“你知道吗？你不在的时候发生了什么我不告诉你。”他拒绝了。我们有新的/旧的科技警报吗？是什么？凯利要问瑞安时间，他会向她展示他iPad上的时钟。关于那个iPad，我们收到了粉丝邮件的狂轰滥炸，安吉拉。来自得克萨斯州达拉斯的埃拉·沃德和许多其他人说，当迈克尔在开始时问安迪戏剧有多长时，安迪说是一个小时45分钟，而且晚上8点整开始，这意味着它应该在9点45分结束。如果加上中场休息，也许10点。但在这集后面
when Ryan shows Kelly what time it is, his clock reads 10.07 and the first act isn't even over. Why is the play already gone two hours and seven minutes before intermission is Ella's question? I went to the script. It's not much of a help because in the script it was scripted to read 9.35, which would still be off timeline wise. I don't know. That's a good catch. Well, ladies, should we take a break? And when we come back, we'll go to intermission because a lot happens. So much happens. We are back and the first thing that happens at intermission is that the director of this stage production, Shelby Thomas Weems, who was played by Phil Abrams and who I could
，当瑞安向凯利展示时间时，他的时钟显示10点07分，而第一幕甚至还没有结束。埃拉的问题是：为什么戏剧在中场休息前就已经进行了两个小时零七分钟？我去查了剧本。这帮不上什么忙，因为在剧本中它被写成9点35分，时间线上仍然有出入。我不知道。这是一个很好的发现。好吧，女士们，我们休息一下好吗？当我们回来时，我们将进入中场休息，因为发生了很多事情。发生了太多事。我们回来了，中场休息时发生的第一件事是，这个舞台制作的导演，谢尔比·托马斯·威姆斯，由菲尔·亚布姆斯饰演，我不能
not have loved more. He's so fantastic. There's more of him in deleted scenes than I share. Really? Oh, I'm so happy to hear that. He comes up to Michael and he says, if you keep auditioning with that same gusto, we will find a part for you, Michael. What is this character he's created? I love Shelby Thomas Weems. There'll be another pep talk from him. I'm gonna save it. I'm gonna save it. Oh, lady. I'm so very excited. Michael is still so sour. He's gonna steal a whole bottle of wine. I love it. Angela is gonna show up dressed in tight jeans and a cute top. They have just her old dirty gardening clothes. What are you talking about? Yeah, Dwight's like, why are you the Steve Cadillac model?
更喜欢他了。他太棒了。删减片段里有更多他的戏份。真的吗？哦，我太高兴听到这个了。他走到迈克尔面前说：“如果你带着那种热情继续试镜，我们会为你找到一个角色的，迈克尔。”这是他创造的什么角色？我爱谢尔比·托马斯·威姆斯。他还有另一次打气谈话。我要留着它。我要留着它。哦，女士。我太兴奋了。迈克尔还是很扫兴。他要偷整整一瓶酒。我喜欢它。安吉拉要穿着紧身牛仔裤和可爱的上衣出现。他们只有她那些旧的脏园艺衣服。你在说什么？是的，德怀特就像，为什么你是西尔斯目录模特？
Yeah, why are you dressed like a seat catalog model? I wanted to read you the stage direction from the shooting draft because there was one little detail that Alicia, our costume designer, had to make sure was on my pair of jeans. What? And it was there for the whole show and I don't think you really catch it. What is it? All right, here you go. Angela approaches Dwight wearing cute jeans and a gingham blouse. They start to exit. In spite of himself, Dwight's eyes linger. The camera finds the clear plastic strip on the jeans that has the size. Clearly this was very calculated. Oh, she had just bought this outfit. She didn't own any of these clothes. She quickly changed and forgot to take the sticker on the side
是的，你为什么穿得像个西尔斯目录模特？我想读给你听拍摄初稿中的舞台动作指导，因为有一处小细节，我们的服装设计艾丽西亚必须确保贴在我的那条牛仔裤上。什么？而且它在整场演出中都在那儿，我觉得你其实没注意到。是什么？好吧，给你这个。安吉拉穿着可爱的牛仔裤和格子衬衫走近德怀特。他们开始离开。尽管克制自己，德怀特的目光还是停留了。镜头找到了牛仔裤上有尺码的透明塑料条。很明显这是经过精心计算的。哦，她刚买了这套衣服。她根本没有这些衣服。她迅速换上了，却忘了把牛仔裤侧面写着尺码的标签撕掉。
of the jeans off that says the size. I've done that so many times. Me too. You walk around all day and then you get home. You go to put it in the laundry and you're like, oh my gosh. Yeah, exactly. Okay. I love this detail because when I saw that outfit, I was like, they made you too cute. What? No, I'm like, I don't even believe it. Like, you looked so stinking cute in this outfit and it was like, it's too sexy. It's too sexy. The seat catalog outfit? The seat catalog outfit. It was such a departure from Angela's regular wardrobe and this makes so much sense. She just bought it. Yeah. And you know what? She's going all out. Did you catch the platform shoes? I did. Well, also during this intermission,
我做过好多次这种事。我也是。你穿着它走了一整天，然后你到家了。你要把它放进洗衣篮，然后你会想：哦，天哪。是的，完全如此。好吧。我喜欢这个细节，因为当我看到那套衣服时，我想，他们把你打扮得太可爱了。什么？不，我是说，我甚至都不相信。就像，你看上去太可爱了，而且有点太性感了。太性感了。西尔斯目录套装？西尔斯目录套装。这与安吉拉平时的衣着大相径庭，而且这太合情合理了。她刚刚买的。而且你知道吗？她全力以赴了。你注意到那双松糕鞋了吗？我注意到了。好吧，同样在这个中场休息期间，
Pam is going to call Erin to check in. And this is where she's going to tell Erin that the play is going great. We talked about the scene a little bit with Ed. Yeah. He liked this line of Pam's. Yeah. I wanted to say that we got some mail from people who were saying they thought that Pam seemed a little unusually tense in this phone call with Erin. Oh, well, I mean, there's a lot more in deleted scenes. I was going to say, before the play started, there was a scene where Erin is texting Pam, but only a CC. Yes, it's so like bonkers. Erin will only communicate with Pam and Jim as if she's CC talking. And that's why in intermission, Pam was like, do not put CC on the phone. She cannot talk. Yeah. That's why
帕姆要打电话给埃里希核实情况。这就是她要告诉艾琳戏剧进展顺利的地方。我们和埃德稍微讨论过这个场景。是的。他喜欢帕姆的这句台词。是的。我想说，我们收到了一些人的信件，他们说他们觉得帕姆在这个和艾琳的电话里显得有点异乎寻常地紧张。哦，好吧，我是说，删减片段里还有更多内容。我要说的是，在戏剧开始之前，有一个场景是艾琳在给帕姆发短信，但只是抄送（CC）。是的，太荒唐了。艾琳只会与帕姆和吉姆交流，就好像她在抄送说话一样。这就是为什么在中场休息时，帕姆会说：“不要让CC接电话。她不能说话。”是的。这就是为什么
there's that edge and urgency to her. Backstage, Andy is checking his email. Any last minute messages from Erin? Nothing. There were more scenes backstage as Andy really starts to get down. He's really bummed out. I loved it so much because we get to see more of the director Shelby Thomas-Waymes. Give him a pep talk. You have to hear it, Jenna, because as an actor, it's that classic pep talk that you get. Can we hear it? Andy. Andy. I know the sadness that you're feeling right now does not feel like a gift, but it is. Use it. Let it inform your performance. Use it. I'm so upset. I just, I think I should go home. Then go home. Conrad can do your part. I'm going to use it. Use it.
她身上有一种急迫和紧迫感。在后台，安迪在检查他的电子邮件。来自艾琳的最后消息？什么都没有。后台还有更多的场景，因为安迪开始真正沮丧起来。他真的很失落。我太喜欢了，因为我们能看到更多关于导演谢尔比·托马斯·威姆斯的戏份。给她打气。你必须听听，珍娜，因为作为演员，那是你得到的经典打气。我们能听听吗？安迪。安迪。我知道你现在感受到的悲伤并不像是一份礼物，但它是。利用它。让它指导你的表演。利用它。我太难过了。我只是，我想我应该回家。那就回家。康拉德可以演你的角色。我要利用它。利用它。
I can do your part. I'm going to use it. There's so many things about the scene that are amazing. He's every director I've ever had. Every theater director. Yeah. I've ever had. Yeah. I really wish you could see. I'm going to record it and show you. I have to put it in stories. When Shelby, the director says, you've got to use it. And then Andy's like, I don't know if I can. He's like, well, then go home. Conrad can play your part. It cuts to Conrad. No. The person who played Conrad gives the most brilliant look like, huh? Like what? It's so good. That needs to be in the episode. It's really fantastic. It really does. While all of that was happening backstage, there's a quick cutaway to the lobby where Creed
我可以演你的角色。我要利用它。关于这个场景有很多令人惊叹的地方。他是我见过的每个导演。每个剧场导演。是的。我都遇到过。是的。我真的很希望你能看到。我要把它录下来给你看。我得把它发到快拍里。当谢尔比，那个导演说：“你必须利用它。”然后安迪说：“我不知道我能不能。”他说：“那回家吧。康拉德可以演你的角色。”镜头切到康拉德。不。扮演康拉德的那个人露出了最精彩的表情，就像：哈？像什么？太棒了。那需要放进正片里。真的很棒。真的。当所有这些都在后台发生时，镜头快速切到了大堂，克里德
is giving a review of the play. Unfavorable review. Yes. His line is, unfortunately, in this ham-fisted production of Sweeney Todd, the real terror comes from the vocal performances. Well, listen, it's act two now. And Michael is drinking from his full bottle of wine. He's passing it around. Yeah. It goes to Daryl to Meredith to Kevin. And we got a fan question. Okay. At 10 minutes 45 seconds, Victoria S. from Chesterfield, Virginia says, I've got to know, was there a storyline cut out involving Kevin and a jacket that he wears to Andy's play? Yes, Victoria, there was. Yes. If you see, he's wearing this like, what do you call that? Like a bomber jacket? Well, they remind me of like the Varsity Athletic Jackets you get when
正在对戏剧给出评价。不喜欢的评价。是的。他的台词是：“不幸的是，在这个笨拙的《理发师陶德》制作中，真正的恐怖来自于声乐表演。”好吧，听着，现在是第二幕了。迈克尔正在喝他那一整瓶酒。他正在把它传着喝。是的。它传给达里尔，传给梅雷迪思，传给凯文。我们有一个粉丝问题。好的。在10分45秒时，来自弗吉尼亚州切斯特菲尔德的维多利亚·S说：“我必须知道，是不是删掉了一条涉及凯文和他在安迪戏剧中穿的一件夹克的剧情线？”是的，维多利亚，确实有。是的。如果你看到，他穿着这个像，你叫那个什么？就像飞行员夹克？嗯，它们让我想起像大学校队夹克，当你
you make the varsity team. It has the leather sleeve and then the fabric on the torso part. Yeah. And it's embroidered with the name Kevin. Yeah. So there was a scene from before the play starts in the lobby. Oscar's looking at old show posters and Kevin walks up wearing a Sweeney Todd jacket. And Oscar's like, Kevin, why'd you buy that? And Kevin's like, it was cold. And then the stage direction said, reveal the jacket is embroidered with Kevin. Now, here's the thing, lady. That's all I could find was that little bit. I was curious about this too, because not only did he buy this very expensive merch, but then he had it personalized and you can't buy it in the moment personalized. They can't just quickly monogram your name on it. That was my thing.
进入校队时获得的那种。它有皮革袖子，然后躯干部分是织物。是的。而且上面绣着名字凯文。是的。所以有一个场景是在戏剧开始前在大堂。奥斯卡正在看旧的演出海报，凯文走过来穿着一件《理发师陶德》的夹克。奥斯卡就像：“凯文，你为什么要买那个？”凯文就像：“天冷。”然后舞台动作指导说：“显露夹克上绣着凯文。”现在，问题是，女士。我能找到的只有那一小段。我对这个也很好奇，因为他不仅买了这件非常昂贵的周边，而且他还把它个性化了，你不能在现场定制个性化。他们不能那么快地把你的名字绣在上面。这就是我的问题。
I wondered if it was a cast member's jacket named Kevin. Well, here's what I found. In the shooting draft, there was a scene where Kevin goes backstage to meet the actress who played Mrs. Lovett. He is a huge fan of hers and has been to every show, kind of implying that he has a big crush on her. Oh, she's a total stranger. This isn't his first time seeing Sweeney Todd. She says you've come to every show. Yeah, he's like kind of obsessed with her. And I think he got the jacket to impress her. Wow. If he had been coming to every run of the show, he had time to order it and get it monogrammed. But in deleted scenes, there is a scene where Kevin goes backstage and he runs up to the person who plays Mrs. Lovett and he says this. Hi. Kevin. Hi. Stuart, this is my brother
我想知道它是不是一件名字叫凯文的演员的夹克。好吧，这是我找到的。在拍摄初稿中，有一个场景是凯文去后台见扮演洛维特夫人的女演员。他是她的超级粉丝，看过每一场演出，这有点暗示他对她有很大的迷恋。哦，她是个完全的陌生人。这已经不是他第一次看《理发师陶德》了。她说你看了每一场演出。是的，他有点对她着迷。我想他是为了给她留下深刻印象才买的夹克。哇。如果他看过该剧的每一场演出，他就有时间订购并把它绣上名字。但在删减片段中，有一个场景是凯文去后台，他跑向扮演洛维特夫人的人，他说这个。嗨。凯文。嗨。斯图尔特，这是我弟弟
Kevin. Hi. I can't believe you came to every show. You're good. Oh, thank you. See, you never come to anything I ever do. So what's the change? We need to put mom in a home. Wait, wait. So in one iteration of this, in the shooting draft, she's a stranger and he's been to every show and he's her biggest fan. I never saw this scripted anywhere. So I don't know if this was something that they handed pages changed right then that day. But in deleted scenes, Mrs. Lovett is Kevin's sister and he's been to every show. Wow. But I think that explains why he bought the jacket. Yeah. We tried to do a little mom detective for you there. Yeah. We need detective did, did, did, did. That jacket would have been really expensive, by the way. A hundred bucks easily. It was nice. Yeah.
凯文。嗨。我真不敢相信你看了每一场演出。你演得真好。哦，谢谢。看，你从来不来看我演的任何东西。所以有什么变化？我们需要把妈妈送进养老院。等等，等等。所以在其中一个版本的构思中，在拍摄初稿里，她是个陌生人，而他看过每一场演出，是她的头号粉丝。我从没在任何地方看到过这个剧本。所以我不知道这是否是他们当天临时发给的修改页。但在删减片段中，洛维特夫人是凯文的姐姐，而且他看过每一场演出。哇。但我觉得这解释了他为什么买这件夹克。是的。我们在那里为你做了一点妈妈侦探的工作。是的。我们需要侦探的音乐。那件夹克顺便说一句真的很贵。100块钱轻松。挺好看的。是的。
We talked about this next scene a little bit with Ed, where Andy's phone rings. Yeah. In the middle of the performance, but that's not the only disturbance is it? No. Michael is trying to set the bottle of wine in between his feet on the floor, knocks it over and it starts to roll down the whole entire audience. This bottle rolls for 19 seconds. It made me laugh every time I want to hear it. Where do you suppose all the rig makers of London go to obtain their human hair? So you think. So you think. It's so long. So you. That's such a long amount of television time, lady. In silence, let a bottle roll.
我们和埃德简单聊过接下来的这个场景，安迪的电话响了。对。在演出进行到一半的时候，但这还不是唯一的骚扰，对吧？没有。迈克尔试图把那瓶酒放在地板上他的双脚之间，结果把它碰倒了，酒瓶开始滚过整个观众席。这个酒瓶滚了整整 19 秒。每次我都笑得不行，我想听听这个。你觉得伦敦的假发制造商都是去哪儿弄的人类头发？所以你觉得。所以你觉得。太长了。所以你。女士，这真是一段很长的电视时间。在安静中，让一个酒瓶滚动。
I looked in the script at the script note and it had a delicious little nugget that says, you think it's done, but it's not. It was so great. I mean, when they were looking at locations, I guess they had to make sure there was no carpeting. Like they had to be able, this was in the script from the beginning. Yeah. Well, that's not even all because then balloons start popping. Yes. Michael loses control of his balloons. They start popping and then a baby starts crying. A baby CC. Aaron has brought CC and is standing in the back of the theater. Andy is so happy. He says she's a terrible babysitter. We had a fan question from Sean M. in Cincinnati who says, Oh my gosh, I have been waiting to ask this question since you all started
我在剧本的剧本备注里看到了一个非常有趣的细节，上面写着：你以为结束了，但并没有。这太棒了。我的意思是，当他们寻找拍摄地点时，我想他们必须确保那里没有地毯。就像他们必须能够做到这一点，这从一开始就在剧本里。是的。好吧，这甚至还不是全部，因为接着气球开始爆了。是的。迈克尔失去了对气球的控制。它们开始爆裂，然后一个婴儿开始哭泣。婴儿西西。埃伦带了西西来，正站在剧院后面。安迪太高兴了。他说她是个糟糕的保姆。我们有一个来自辛辛那提的粉丝肖恩·M 的提问，他说，哦天哪，自从你们开始
this podcast. No, scratch that. I've been waiting to ask this question since this episode first aired 11 years ago. Oh my goodness. At 13 minutes and 56 seconds, why is Meredith climbing onto the stage behind Andy's talking head? Please tell me there is an answer because it keeps me up at night and I just need this mystery solved. Sean, you've held on to this for a long time. Did you notice it, Ange? Because I didn't even notice it. Sean, I didn't even notice it and I watched this episode four times. I went back and looked at it and sure enough, yes, Meredith is climbing on stage behind Andy's talking head. So I went to the script and there is a very odd stage direction that is supported by nothing but does say this. Behind Andy, we see Meredith climb onto stage and jump up and down.
这个播客以来，我一直等着问这个问题。不对，划掉。自从这一集 11 年前首播以来，我一直等着问这个问题。哦天哪。在 13 分钟 56 秒时，为什么梅雷迪思会爬上安迪单人访谈背后的舞台？请告诉我答案，因为它让我夜不能寐，我只是需要解开这个谜团。肖恩，你这个问题憋了很久了。安吉，你注意到了吗？因为我甚至都没注意到。肖恩，我甚至都没注意到，而且这一集我看了四遍。我又回去看了一遍，果然，是的，梅雷迪思正爬上安迪单人访谈背后的舞台。于是我查阅了剧本，里面有一个非常奇怪的舞台指示，没有任何上下文支持，但确实是这样写的：在安迪身后，我们看到梅雷迪思爬上舞台并上下跳跃。
I think it was just meant to be like an extension of the mayhem that it was like bottle, balloons, baby, Andy's giving this talking head. Meredith is jumping on stage. Well, Meredith had drank most of that bottle of wine. I think that's what it is when they passed it around. Yeah, she held on to it for a bit. Exactly. Wow. Sean, I did not catch that. That is hilarious. Everyone can look for it now. Great background catch. Real good. Jim and Pam are so ticked off. They're going to take Cece home. Pam says they won't ever be leaving the house together again. Yeah. This is our first time getting to meet little baby Cece. What a cutie. We used twins for Cece. They were Sienna and Bailey Stroll and they played Cece for the bulk of the show.
我想这只是为了表现混乱的延续，就像酒瓶、气球、婴儿、安迪正在做单人访谈。梅雷迪思在舞台上跳跃。嗯，梅雷迪思喝掉了大半瓶酒。我想当他们把酒传阅一圈时就是这样。是的，她拿了一会儿。完全正确。哇，肖恩，我真没注意到。太搞笑了。大家现在可以去找找看了。非常棒的背景细节捕捉。真的很不错。吉姆和帕姆气坏了。他们要把西西带回家。帕姆说他们再也不会一起离开家了。是的。这是我们第一次见到小婴儿西西。真是个小可爱。我们为西西用了双胞胎。她们是西耶娜·斯特罗尔和贝利·斯特罗尔，在剧集的大部分时间里都由她们扮演西西。
They were just the sweetest kids. Their parents were wonderful. I just loved these girls when I saw myself holding that little baby. I mean, I held those girls a lot. A lot. I was with them a lot. You spent a lot of time with them too off camera so they'd be comfortable with you. Yeah. You were so great with them. Oh, I would love to see them again. I know. Wouldn't that be amazing? What's it like for them to know that they were baby Cece on the office? I wonder because they're like, I can't believe it. They must be almost teenagers now. Yeah. Maybe they, are they like 13 now? I think they are, lady. They'd have to be close and age to Isabel because when we filmed this episode, Isabel was a year and a half old.
她们真的是最甜美的孩子。她们的父母也很好。当我看到自己抱着那个小婴儿时，我真的很喜欢这些女孩。我的意思是，我经常抱这两个女孩。经常。我和她们呆在一起很多时间。你花了很多时间在镜头外陪她们，这样她们才会觉得和你在一起很自在。是的。你对她们太好了。哦，我很想再次见到她们。我知道。那不是很神奇吗？对她们来说，知道自己在《办公室》里演过婴儿西西，是一种什么样的体验？我想知道，因为她们会觉得，我真不敢相信。她们现在一定快成青少年了吧。对。也许她们，现在大概 13 岁了吧？我想是的，女士。她们的年龄一定和伊莎贝尔差不多，因为我们拍摄这一集时，伊莎贝尔一岁半。
Oh my goodness. I know. I measure everything. It's like that thing you do where you measure everything that happened in your life by how old your child was. I do that a lot for the office. I have pre baby years and then post baby years on the office. Yes. Well, unfortunately for Stanley, there will be a standing ovation. He's going to have to get up. There is. It seems to be motivated when the actor playing Sweeney Todd comes out on stage. People loved his performance. Michael starts to boo him. Boo's him. So rude. Meanwhile, outside, Angela and Dwight are looking for Angela's car in the parking lot. Did you catch this couplet of dialogue when Dwight and Angela are talking about how bad
哦天哪。我知道。我用一切来衡量。就像你做的那样，你用你的孩子多大了来衡量你生活中发生的一切。我经常用这个来衡量《办公室》的生活。我在《办公室》里有生孩子前的几年，然后是生孩子后的几年。是的。好吧，不幸的是对斯坦利来说，会有一次起立鼓掌。他得站起来。确实有。这似乎是在扮演斯威尼·托德的演员上台时被带动的。人们非常喜欢他的表演。迈克尔开始嘘他。嘘他。太粗鲁了。与此同时，在外面，安吉拉和德怀特正在停车场找安吉拉的车。当德怀特和安吉拉在讨论
the show was? And Angela says that was more horrifying than nonsense. Did you catch that she said nonsense? That's the name of the show. Yes. She doesn't say nonsense. Some people thought that she says nonsense. So nonsense was a musical comedy written by Dan Gogan. It's very famous lady. Nonsense. Yeah. I wasn't familiar with it. Well, you know who is familiar with it? Who? Our very own Phyllis Smith. She starred in Nonsense at the St. Louis Muny. That's right. So you guys, here's the plot of Nonsense. The show starts when the little sisters of Hoboken discovered that their cook, Sister Julia, had accidentally poisoned 52 of her sisters.
这个演出有多糟糕时，你注意到这段对话了吗？安吉拉说这比胡闹还要可怕。你注意到她说的是胡闹吗？那是剧名的意思。是的。她说的不是胡闹。有些人以为她说的是胡闹。所以胡闹是一部由丹·戈根创作的音乐喜剧。女士，这非常有名。胡闹。是的。我不太熟悉。好吧，你知道谁熟悉吗？谁？我们自己的菲利斯·史密斯。她曾在圣路易斯蒙尼剧院主演过《胡闹》。没错。所以大家，以下是《胡闹》的剧情：演出开始于霍博肯修道院的小修女们发现她们的厨师朱莉娅修女不小心毒死了 52 名修女。
They are in dire need of funds for the burials. The sisters decide that the best way to raise the money is to put on a variety show. So they take over the school auditorium, which is currently set up for the eighth grade production of Grease. You meet all of the nuns. It's a full-on musical. It features tap dancing, ballet dancing, an audience quiz, comic surprises, and it became an international phenomenon. Well, we got a fan question from Candy Bee in Cartersville, Georgia, who said, my girlfriends and I make an annual pilgrimage to the Muny in St. Louis. Angela, the Muny is this huge outdoor amphitheater. And every year they put on a variety of big musical productions. So fun. When there is a kid, it's so big that you need binoculars sometimes to see
她们急需资金来举行葬礼。修女们决定筹集资金的最佳方式是举办一场杂技汇演。于是她们占用了学校礼堂，这里目前正为八年级制作的《油脂》做准备。你会遇到所有的修女。这是一部成熟的音乐剧。它包括踢踏舞、芭蕾舞、观众问答、喜剧惊喜，并成为了一个国际现象。好吧，我们收到了来自佐治亚州卡特斯维尔的坎迪·B 的粉丝提问，她说，我和我的好朋友们每年都会去圣路易斯蒙尼剧院朝圣。安吉拉，蒙尼剧院是一个巨大的露天圆形剧场。他们每年都会上演各种大型音乐剧作品。太有趣了。如果有小孩，剧场太大了，有时候如果你坐在后面，你需要望远镜才能看到
the stage if you're back far enough. But that's like part of it. Like, I would go as a kid, we'd get the binoculars and you watch the show. Candy said, one time we got to see Phyllis Smith perform in Nonsense. When she made her entrance on stage, she got a big laugh because another character asked her where she had been for so long. And Phyllis pointed offstage and said, over there in the office. That was her line, over there in the office. That's fantastic. Dwight and Angela's scene will continue. And I wanted to read you guys the stage direction in the shooting draft. Oh, lady, I wrote it down too. Oh, it says Angela stops and turns towards the wind, looking for her car, looking as in quotes. The moon lights up her face,
舞台。但这也是其中一部分。就像，我小时候去，我们会拿着望远镜看演出。坎迪说，有一次我们看到菲利斯·史密斯在《胡闹》中表演。当她登台时，她赢得了满堂大笑，因为另一个角色问她去了那么久去了哪里。菲利斯指着台下说，那边，在办公室。那是她的台词，那边，在办公室。太棒了。德怀特和安吉拉的场景将继续。我想给你们读一下拍摄初稿中的舞台指示。哦，女士，我也写下来了。哦，上面写着安吉拉停下来，转身迎着风，寻找她的车，寻找打上了引号。月光照亮了她的脸，
the wind blows through her hair. She looks stunning in a natural normal way we've never seen. Dwight is taken aback. I loved this phrasing, a natural normal way we've never seen. And lady Lexi T from Bermuda wrote in and said, damn, Angela, you look amazing. Go lady. Thank you. It was, it was like exactly perfect. Did they have a fan to blow your hair? They had a fan and I had to turn just right so my hair didn't blow across my face. Yeah. And they also put little twinkly lights in the trees to kind of make it look a little bit more, you know, romantic. The scene was really fun to do, especially playing someone who was so buttoned up for years to finally just even be in a normal outfit. Yeah. Here's how the
风吹过她的头发。她以一种我们从未见过的那种自然而正常的方式显得惊艳。德怀特大吃一惊。我喜欢这种措辞，一种我们从未见过的那种自然而正常的方式。来自百慕大的女士莱克西·T 写信说，天哪，安吉拉，你看起来棒极了。加油，女士。谢谢。这真是，简直完美。他们有风扇来吹你的头发吗？他们有个风扇，我必须转到刚刚好的角度，这样我的头发才不会吹到脸上。是的。他们还在树上挂了些一闪一闪的小灯，为了让它看起来更浪漫一点。拍摄这个场景真的很有趣，尤其是扮演一个多年来一直那么死板的人，最后终于能穿上正常的衣服。是的。以下是
scene continued in the shooting draft. Angela leans in to Dwight. She reaches for his pants. Dwight sighs. She reaches into his pocket and pulls out the whole punch. Dwight says, was that in the way? Get rid of it. She punches the card and hands it back to him. Good night, Dwight. Angela climbs in her car. Dwight watches her completely frustrated. Yeah. He wanted to get it on. And she was like, no, no, this will count. Just coming to the play with me. She's leaving him wanting more. We had to figure out exactly how we were going to choreograph that scene. And, you know, rain is so much taller than me. So we were trying to figure out what their embrace looked like. And, you know, he picked me up fairly easily. So we went with that.
拍摄初稿中场景的延续。安吉拉向德怀特靠过去。她伸手去掏他的裤子。德怀特叹了口气。她把手伸进他的口袋，掏出了打孔器。德怀特说，这个挡路了吗？把它扔掉吧。她用打孔器打了个孔，然后还给他。晚安，德怀特。安吉拉钻进车里。德怀特看着她，满脸沮丧。是的。他本来想亲热一番的。而她的态度是，不，不，这就够了。只要陪我来看戏就行。她让他意犹未尽。我们必须弄清楚如何确切地编排那个场景。而且，你知道，雷恩比我高得多。所以我们一直在试图弄清楚他们的拥抱看起来是什么样的。而且，你知道，他很容易就把我抱起来了。所以我们就用了那个。
We had a fan catch from Maddie M in Minneapolis who said old tech alert at 17 minutes and 20 seconds, Angela had to use the key to manually unlock her car door. Yes. Backstage at the after party, Michael can be found eating dried apricots. He's eaten 30 of them. I had to look that up, lady. That seemed like too many. He's had 30 dried apricots and a bunch of red wine. How's the rest of that evening going to play out? Well, I'll tell you the recommended daily consumption of dried apricots is three to four per day. What? He ate 30? He's eaten 10 times. The recommended amount? Oh no. It was about 480 calories of dried apricots. And if you eat too much dried fruit in one sitting, it can cause gas, abdominal cramping, bloating constipation,
我们收到了明尼阿波利斯的麦迪·M 的粉丝捕捉，她说老科技警报，在 17 分钟 20 秒时，安吉拉不得不使用钥匙手动解锁车门。是的。在庆功宴后台，迈克尔在吃杏干。他吃了 30 个。女士，我不得不去查一下。那听起来太多了。他吃了 30 个杏干和一堆红酒。那天晚上的其余时间会怎么发展？好吧，我告诉你们，推荐的每日杏干摄入量是每天三到四个。什么？他吃了 30 个？他吃的是推荐量的 10 倍？哦不。那是大约 480 卡路里的杏干。如果你一次吃太多干果，会导致胀气、腹部痉挛、腹胀、便秘、
or possibly diarrhea. Oh. So that's what? That's what's ahead of Michael. He has coming. This is when Sweeney Todd, who was played by Robert Mimana comes up. Darrell says, you crushed it. You did great. And he sees Michael and says, you're the guy that booed me. Michael was like, there are a lot of people booing you. That wasn't just me. And he's like, no, it was you. And Darrell really calls Michael out on it. He's like, how would you like that? And he starts booing him. Michael doesn't like it at all. The actor who played Sweeney Todd has done a ton of stuff. He's done television dramas, but also a ton of theater. He graduated from the University of Arizona with a Bachelor of Fine Arts,
或者可能腹泻。哦。所以这就是什么？这就是等待迈克尔的。他要倒霉了。这时，由罗伯特·米曼纳扮演的斯威尼·托德走了过来。达里尔说，你太棒了。你干得好。他看到迈克尔说，你就是那个嘘我的人。迈克尔的反应是，有很多人在嘘你啊。不只是我。而他的反应是，不，就是你。达里尔真的当面质问迈克尔了。他说，要是别人这么对你，你作何感想？然后他开始嘘迈克尔。迈克尔非常不喜欢这样。扮演斯威尼·托德的演员演过超级多作品。他演过电视剧，但也演过大量的戏剧。他毕业于亚利桑那大学艺术学士学位，
and he has been nominated and won several awards for theater. He really was our ringer. Yeah. Well, Andy and Erin are going to have just, you know, their usual sweet but weird scene. Yep, where Andy is going to show her how Sweeney Todd would kill people in the barber chair, and they're just having the best time. And she says, I'm so glad we're hanging out outside of work again. Yeah. And then he takes her into the audience and he shows her where her seats would have been, how it's the exact perfect spot to get the right acoustics. It seems far back, but it's actually the best sound. And that's when Gabe calls. He needs some soup. Cape. They've really written him like a wet blanket.
并且曾获得多项戏剧奖提名并获奖。他真的是我们的秘密武器。是的。好吧，安迪和埃伦将有一场，你知道的，他们日常那种甜蜜又奇怪的场景。是的，安迪要向她展示斯威尼·托德在理发椅上是如何杀人的，他们玩得正开心。她说，我很高兴我们又能在一起玩了，除了工作之外。是的。然后他把她带到观众席，向她展示她的座位会在哪里，以及如何成为获得正确声学效果的绝佳位置。看起来很远，但实际上声音效果最好。就在这时，加布打电话来了。他需要一些汤。加布。他们真的把他写得像个扫兴鬼。
He is. It's true. Well, Jim and Pam get home and they have that classic parent moment where the kid is happy in the car seat. Maybe she's fallen asleep and they know if they get her out of that car seat, she's going to wake up. So they decide to have their own nightcap out in the car. Well, we got a fan question and from Samantha G in Florida who said, this is more of a request than a question in a continuation of your scotch and splendor sampling. Oh no. No, we're not going to have Irish cream and orange juice. No. Samantha said, I wanted to see if you would be willing to brave orange juice and Irish cream. Samantha.
他确实是。真的。好吧，吉姆和帕姆回到家，他们经历了那种典型的父母时刻，孩子在安全座椅里很高兴。也许她睡着了，他们知道如果把她从安全座椅里弄出来，她就会醒过来。所以他们决定在车里享受他们自己的深夜小酌。好吧，我们收到了来自佛罗里达州萨曼莎·G 的粉丝提问，她说，与其说这是一个问题，不如说是一个请求，这是对你们苏格兰威士忌加代糖品尝的延续。哦不。不，我们才不要喝爱尔兰奶油加橙汁呢。不。萨曼莎说，我想看看你们是否愿意勇敢地尝试橙汁加爱尔兰奶油。萨曼莎。
It sounds like a terrible combination, but I'd love for you ladies to take one for the team and give it a try. So lady, I brought in some Irish cream and orange juice. You did not. I cannot believe you bought Irish cream and orange juice. I'll go get it. It's in the fridge. Are you supposed to refrigerate Irish cream? I don't know. I've never even had it. I wasn't sure. I've never had Irish cream. It's like whiskey and cream, right? And you mix that with orange juice? I mean, normally you put it in your coffee, I think. Oh, yeah. Yeah. All right. I'll go get it. All right. Jenna has gotten the Irish cream and orange juice.
听起来是个糟糕的组合，但我希望你们女士们能为团队做出牺牲，尝试一下。所以女士，我带了一些爱尔兰奶油和橙汁。你没有。我简直不敢相信你买了爱尔兰奶油和橙汁。我去拿。在冰箱里。爱尔兰奶油需要冷藏吗？我不知道。我甚至都没喝过。我不确定。我从没喝过爱尔兰奶油。就像威士忌加奶油，对吧？然后你把它和橙汁混合？我的意思是，通常你会把它加到咖啡里吧。哦，是的。是的。好吧。我去拿。好的。珍娜已经拿到了爱尔兰奶油和橙汁。
I have it. Now, I don't know what proportions I'm doing here. I'm so sad that Sam isn't here today. I feel like he would want to be a part of this. Sorry, Sam, but you're on a lovely vacation. Abby, our guest engineer, surprise. You get Irish cream and orange juice. Just what you've always wanted. This probably disgusting drink. What do I, what do you think? How much orange juice and how much Irish cream? I feel like it should be mostly orange juice. I mean, no, not on me. Go light on orange juice. Light on orange juice. Heavy on Irish cream? Well, am I supposed to shake this first? Why do I feel like I should shake it?
我拿到了。现在，我不知道我在这里用的比例是什么。我很遗憾山姆今天不在这里。我觉得他会想参与其中的。对不起，山姆，不过你在享受美妙的假期。艾比，我们的客座工程师，惊喜。你得到了爱尔兰奶油和橙汁。这正是你一直想要的。这杯可能很恶心的饮料。我觉得，你觉得呢？多少橙汁，多少爱尔兰奶油？我觉得应该大部分是橙汁。我的意思是，不，别弄我身上。橙汁少一点。橙汁少一点。爱尔兰奶油多一点？好吧，我是应该先摇匀这个吗？为什么我觉得我应该摇一下？
No, don't shake it. Don't shake it. Found a recipe. Oh, there's a recipe? Yeah. It looks like five eighths a cup of Irish cream and then one and a half cups orange juice. So it's mostly orange juice. Yeah. All right. Okay. And then you are supposed to stir it or try blending it. Blending it. Well, you know what? Jim and Bam didn't blend anything. Oh, it's curdling. That looks disgusting. We need to stir it. It's not mixing together. It looks like someone vomited in their orange juice. Angela, this is yours. It's more Irish cream. No, follow the recipe.
不，别摇。别摇。找到一个食谱。哦，有食谱吗？是的。看起来像是八分之五杯的爱尔兰奶油，然后是一杯半的橙汁。所以大部分是橙汁。好的。好吧。然后你要搅拌它或者试着把它打匀。打匀。你知道吗？吉姆和帕姆可没打匀任何东西。哦，它在结块。看起来真恶心。我们需要搅拌一下。它没有融合在一起。看起来像有人把呕吐物吐进了橙汁里。安吉拉，这是你的。爱尔兰奶油更多。不，照着食谱做。
That's what you said. You wanted it with the more weird curdling stuff. We need something to stir it. I'm going to go get a spoon. Okay. Cold, please. Okay. Here's a spoon. It's not really helping. The spoon is not doing anything. These two liquids don't want to go together. That's clear to me. Okay. There we go. Cassie, Abby, they are not running in. Other times, I mean, there's no movement from them. They have not left their chairs. They clearly don't want to drink. You don't have to. I want to go on record that for my beet vodka, people came in here at least at a quicker pace than this.
这就是你说的。你想要更多那种奇怪结块的东西。我们需要点东西来搅拌。我去拿个勺子。好的，请拿冷的。好的。给你个勺子。没什么用。勺子根本不管用。这两种液体根本不想融合在一起。这对我来说很清楚。好吧。好了。卡西，艾比，她们没有跑过来。其他时候，我是说，她们没有移动。她们没有离开椅子。她们显然不想喝。你们不用喝。我要记录在案，对于我的甜菜伏特加，人们走到这里的速度至少比这快。
Oh, yeah. I was excited for beet vodka. This is, this looks really scary. Yeah. It looks disgusting. Abby did not know what she was getting into when she was like, I'd love to fill in for Sam today. Everyone say hi, Abby. Here we go. Here we go. Oh, it's not bad. Yeah, it kind of tastes like a creamsicle. Yeah, it is. It tastes like a creamsicle. Yeah. It's not as bad as it looks. It looks really gross. It looks disgusting. I can't taste any of the alcohol. It just sort of tastes like creamy orange juice.
哦，是的。我当时对甜菜伏特加很兴奋。这个，看起来真的很吓人。是的。看起来很恶心。艾比当时并不知道她要面对的是什么，当她说，我今天很乐意替班山姆时。大家跟艾比打个招呼。我们开始吧。我们开始吧。哦，不赖。是的，有点像冰淇淋的感觉。是的，确实是。尝起来像冰淇淋。是的。没有看起来那么糟糕。看起来真的很恶心。看起来真恶心。我尝不到任何酒精味。它只是尝起来有点像奶油橙汁。
It's not the worst thing in the world. Well, paint me surprised. Yeah. I mean, Scotch and Splenda, total surprise. Beet vodka, absolute surprise. And this one, not as bad as it sounds. Not as bad as it looks. I'm not going to order it. Like I would maybe order a Scotch and Splenda. The look of it is so foul. It's just foul looking, but it doesn't taste as bad. Well, Samantha, there you have it. Can I say something? I hope so. It's not sitting in my stomach good. I wouldn't take another drink, lady. I would stop drinking it. It's turning on me.
不是世上最糟糕的事情。好吧，我真吃惊。我是说，苏格兰威士忌加代糖，完全是个惊喜。甜菜伏特加，绝对是个惊喜。而这个，没有听起来那么糟糕。没有看起来那么糟糕。我不会点它的。就像我可能会点一杯苏格兰威士忌加代糖一样。它的外表太糟糕了。就是外表很糟糕，但尝起来没那么坏。好吧，萨曼莎，就是这样。我能说句话吗？希望如此。它在我的胃里感觉不太好。女士，我不会再喝第二口了。我要停止喝酒了。它开始让我反胃了。
Is it really? Mm-hmm. That one tastes more like orange juice than anything else, which is good. You know that acid-y feeling you get in your throat after you've thrown up? Oh, no. I'm taking a sip of water now. Yeah, I used my water glass. I'm going to take that water. Okay. Well, fair warning. It could turn on you. All right. Okay. I will continue. Oh, yeah. I feel like I have a little bit of heartburn all of a sudden. Right. Yeah. Are you guys feeling the heartburn in there a little bit? Nothing yet, but now I'm scared.
真的吗？嗯哼。那个尝起来比别的更像橙汁，这倒挺好。你知道呕吐后喉咙里的那种酸溜溜的感觉吗？哦，不。我现在喝口水。对，我用了我的水杯。我要喝那口水。好吧，友情提醒。它可能会让你反胃。好的。好吧。我继续。哦，是的。我突然觉得有点心口灼热。对。是的。你们在那里面也觉得有点心口灼热吗？还没，不过我现在害怕了。
I'm really glad we're near the end. I'm glad this didn't come earlier in the episode. All right. I should eat a banana or something. Yeah. Where are we? I can't even get to the tree. Okay. We are... Andy is moping backstage for where we are, and we're about to have that great scene that we talked about with Ed. I absolutely love the scene. Everyone's like, Andy, you were so great. Come on. Sing us a song. Sing a song. And he starts to sing and... Sorry. It's making me burp. I told you. I mean, how many sips did we take? Like two. And it is immediately... Like, my body is rejecting it. It didn't taste bad,
我真高兴我们快到尾声了。我很高兴这没有在剧集早期出现。好吧。我应该吃根香蕉什么的。好吧。我们在哪儿？我甚至都够不到树了。好吧。我们是……安迪在后台闷闷不乐，我们马上要上演我们和埃德谈论过的那个精彩场景了。我绝对爱惨了这个场景。每个人都说，安迪，你太棒了。来吧。给我们唱首歌。唱首歌。然后他开始唱歌，然后……抱歉。这让我打嗝。我告诉过你们。我是说，我们喝了多少口？就两口。然后立刻……就像，我的身体在排斥它。尝起来并不坏，
but my body is saying don't... My eyes said don't drink that. First, visually, my eyes were like, don't put that in your body. But now my body is never wanting me to ingest that again. I took three sips. I told that third sip. Is like, I feel like something's burning in my chest. Okay. I'm so sorry. I had to burp. Who wrote that? Who wrote this episode? Charlie Grandy. Charlie. What have you done to us?
但我的身体在说不要……我的眼睛说不要喝那个。首先，从视觉上，我的眼睛就像在说，不要把那个吃进身体里。但现在我的身体再也不想摄入那个了。我喝了三口。我告诉过你第三口。就像，我觉得有什么东西在我的胸口燃烧。好吧。非常抱歉。我不得不打嗝。谁写的？谁写的这一集？查理·格兰迪。查理。你对我们做了什么？
Okay. Anyway, everyone gathers around. I absolutely love this. Darryl starts to play Macy Gray's I Try on the piano and Andy sings his heart out. I went to the shooting draft, Jenna, because I wanted to see if it mentioned the Celine Dion song that Randy told us about. Yeah. It doesn't. This is what it says in the shooting draft. Darryl starts to play, I would do anything for love by meatloaf. Oh my goodness. And Andy starts to sing and I would do anything for love. I'd run right into hell and back. I would do anything for love. I'll never lie to you. And that's a fact. As Andy sings, Bob puts his arm around him. Oh, that's the shooting draft.
好吧，不管怎样，大家聚了过来。我太喜欢这个了。达里尔开始在钢琴上弹奏梅茜·格雷的《I Try》，安迪倾情歌唱。珍娜，我去了拍摄初稿，因为我想看看里面是否提到了兰迪告诉我们的席琳·迪翁的歌。是的。并没有。拍摄初稿里是这么写的。达里尔开始演奏，肉块乐队的《I Would Do Anything for Love》。哦天哪。然后安迪开始唱，我愿意为爱做任何事。我愿意赴汤蹈火。我愿意为爱做任何事。我绝不会对你撒谎。千真万确。当安迪唱歌时，鲍勃搂住了他的肩膀。哦，那是拍摄初稿。
Well, Randy told us that this song, Macy Gray's I Try, cost $25,000 and that Craig Robinson pre-recorded his keyboard track. So while we're shooting, Craig is just pretending to play. And the reason that they did this was so that they could keep the tempo of every take the same during editing. So they could cut between. The episode is going to end. We mentioned this very briefly with Ed with my favorite tag, I think maybe ever in the series. We are going to see Michael's audition where he performs an entire episode of Law and Order, including the opening and all musical interludes. It starts with, in the criminal justice system, the people are defended by two separate but equally important groups, the police who investigate the crimes
好吧，兰迪告诉我们，这首歌，梅茜·格雷的《I Try》，花了 25,000 美元，而且克雷格·鲁滨逊预先录制了他的键盘音轨。所以在我们拍摄时，克雷格只是在假装弹奏。他们这样做的原因是为了在剪辑过程中保持每个镜头的节奏一致。这样他们就可以在镜头之间切换。这一集要结束了。我们和埃德非常简短地提到了我最喜欢的尾声，可能也是全剧我最喜欢的。我们将看到迈克尔的试镜，他表演了一整集的《法律与秩序》，包括开场和所有的音乐插曲。开头是，在刑事司法系统中，人民由两组各自独立但同等重要的群体所代表，负责调查罪行的警察，
and the district attorneys who prosecute the offenders. These are their stories. And Michael goes kong kong. Well, you know my love of law and order. So I thoroughly enjoyed Michael's whole monologue. I needed it to go on. I couldn't get enough of it. I could not get enough of it. I went to deleted scenes. I wanted to know if there was more. Unfortunately, I couldn't find any other footage. This is an email to Dave Rogers, I think. It is the holder of all footage. It is absolutely brilliant. Every single second of it is magic. And you guys, that was Andy's play. Yes. And a big thank you to Ed Helms who joined us in studio today. You can catch Ed's series, Rutherford Falls on Peacock. It's wonderful. Ed,
以及起诉罪犯的地方检察官。这就是他们的故事。然后迈克尔发出了“咚咚”声。好吧，你知道我对《法律与秩序》的喜爱。所以我非常享受迈克尔的整段独白。我希望它能继续下去。我看不够。我真的看不够。我去了删减片段。我想知道是否还有更多片段。不幸的，我找不到任何其他素材。这是一封发给戴夫·罗杰斯的邮件，我想是这样的。他是所有素材的持有者。绝对太精彩了。里面的每一秒都是魔法。各位，那就是安迪的戏剧。是的。非常感谢今天加入我们工作室的埃德·海尔姆斯。大家可以在 Peacock 上观看埃德的剧集《瀑布镇》。非常精彩。埃德，
we love you. And thank you to Randy Cordray for such great behind the scenes details. And now here is Ed Helms as Andy singing, My Heart Will Go On by Celine Dion. Every night in my dreams, I see you, I feel you. That is how I know you go on. Far across the distance and spaces, between us, you've come to show you go on. Near, far, wherever you are, I believe that the heart does go on. Once more, you open the door, and you're here in my heart, and my heart will go on and on. Love can touch us one time, and last for a lifetime, and never let go till we're gone. Love was when I loved you, one true time I owe to, and in my life we'll always go on.
我们爱你。也感谢兰迪·科德雷提供如此精彩的幕后细节。现在，这是埃德·海尔姆斯饰演的安迪演唱的席琳·迪翁的《我心永恒》。我梦中的每一个夜晚，我都看到你，我感受到你。这就是我如何知道你仍在继续。跨越遥远的距离和我们之间的空间，你来向我证明你仍在继续。无论近在咫尺，还是远在天边，我相信心会永远继续。再次开启这扇门，你就在我的心中，我的心将永不停息。爱可以触动我们一次，并持续一生，直到我们离去永不放手。爱是在我爱过你的时候，我亏欠的那一次真爱，在我的人生中将永远继续。
Far, far, wherever you are, I believe that the heart does go on. Yes it does. Once more, you open the door, and you're here in my heart, and my heart will go on and on. There's nothing I fear, and I know that my heart will go on. I will stay forever this way, you're safe in my heart, and my heart will go on and on. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies. Office Ladies is produced by Earwolf, Jenna Fisher, and Angela Kinsey. Our show is executive produced by Cody Fisher. Our producer is Cassie Jerkins, our sound engineer is Sam Kiefer, and our associate producer is Ainsley Bubicoe. Our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton. For ad-free
远在天边，无论你在哪里，我相信心会永远继续。确实如此。再次开启这扇门，你就在我的心中，我的心将永不停息。我无所畏惧，我知道我的心将永远继续。我将永远这样留存，你在我心中安然无恙，我的心将永不停息。感谢收听“办公室女士”。“办公室女士”由 Earwolf、珍娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金西制作。我们的节目由科迪·费舍尔执行制作。我们的制作人是卡西·杰金斯，我们的声音工程师是萨姆·基弗，我们的副制作人是艾斯利·布比科。我们的主题曲是克里·布拉顿的《橡胶树》。想要收听无广告版
versions of Office Ladies, go to StitcherPremium.com. For a free one-month trial of Stitcher Premium, use code, OFFICE. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
本的“办公室女士”，请访问 StitcherPremium.com。如需免费试用一个月的 Stitcher Premium，请使用代码 OFFICE。这一集目前还没有评论。点击剧本中的任意句子即可留下评论。